artificial intelligence is
revolutionizing the way we interact with
technology chat GPD and AI driven
chatboard is a prime example of this
Innovation with its ability to engage in
natural conversations and understand
context Chad GPT is reshaping customer
service and automation making it a key
player in the world of AI in this chat
GPT full course we will explore how chat
GPT is useful in various domains what is
Chad GPT and how to use Chad GPT how
strong are the competitors of chat GPT
and much more so before we begin
consider subscribing to Simply learn and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us over to our tutors on
that note enhance your professional
prospects through enrollment and
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn offered in
partnership with both Pur University and
IBM acquire sought after competencies
encompassing machine learning deep
learning natural language processing
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and a merid of other Cutting Edge
topics one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box whether you're a
tech Enthusiast a expert or just curious
about the new and exciting development
you won't want to miss this discussion
about the latest a sensation I'm talking
talking about Chad gbt a highly Advanced
language model based on gpt3 technology
developed by open AI Chad gbt is a state
of art language generation AI model that
has captured the attention of millions
of people around the world it has been
trained on a massive data set of text
Data making it one of the most largest
language models to date but do you know
a new version of GPD is coming up it's
called GPT 4 and it will support up to 1
trillion parameters compared to 175
billion parameters of gpt3 three now you
might be wondering what are these
parameters so what it means when a user
sends a query to the newer version of
chat gbt then it will process that query
with all one trilon parameters to
deliver a correct and suitable response
isn't it mind-blowing not only that gp4
will have more applications than its
predecessor gpt3 the gpt3 has various
applications like text generation text
summarization automated content
generation application and is also being
used by various companies like viable
feable Studio and algolia aside from its
remarkable language handling ability GPD
4 has the possibility of being utilized
for additional functions such as
generating images and videos this is due
to the fact gbd4 is constructed using
the Transformer architecture which has
demonstrated Effectiveness in multiple
machine learning assignments including
computer vision psychologist and
cognitive scientist Gary marker said
that he can guarantee that gp4 will blow
the minds He also mentioned that gp4
will totally Eclipse Chad gbt as it has
more parameters and is being trained
with more data however the CEO Sam Alman
debunks false information surrounding
the company's upcoming chat GPT 4 Alman
said that he did not have an actual AGI
that is an artificial general
intelligence that could drial humans in
learning and existence the release of
Chad GPT and other AI power Chad BS had
had a major impact on Google search
business with the New York Times
reporting that it prompted Google's
management to declare State emergency
referred to as Cod red GPD 4 with its
improved complexity and quicker response
time has the potential to enhance
communication by making it more natural
and accurate for instance short sentence
responses from a chatboard can reduce
the likelihood of people clicking on ads
this AI technology could bring about a
major transformation in the economy
Google employees have been assigned the
task of developing AI products with gp4
that can match the capability of gpt3
such as its capability of generating art
music and other visuals that open a is
currently capable of Microsoft has
invested $3 billion into the open Ai and
is reportedly in discussion to invest an
additional 10 billion as reported by the
New York Times the paper also stated
that the release of gp4 is expected to
take place in the first quarter of 2023
Matt mlan a venture capitalist with
knowledge of gbd4 hinted that the new
system May possesses multimodel
capabilities which refers to the
capability of functioning in various mod
such as text images and sounds the gp4
chatboard built using Microsoft
extensive data center network has the
potential to be similar to chat gbd
generating only text or it could be
incorporate both text and images however
Sam Alman has caution not to set
expectations too high so at this point
it is difficult to say with certainty
what GPT 4 will look like and what it
will be capable of so what do you think
about Chad gbt 4 do let us know in the
comment section below we'll start with a
chat jbt to automate our Excel and we
have some Excel files I will upload them
in the link with the GitHub so you can
freely download them and you can also
try this project with those files and
here we are with the chat jpt so now we
are on the chat jpt website and here you
can see that there's a try chat jpd
option and when we click it we will be
redirecting to the chat jpt the chat box
and before that I will show you the
homepage it's showing us the samples
what we can do with the chat
GPT the
methods and there's the collect
demonstration data and train a
supervised policy like how it's trained
how open has trained the chgb and its
limitations they have mentioned all the
things here itive deployment
and moving on now we will log in to our
chat
jpt I will log in with my Google
account tell us about you and this is my
name and he's ask
asking my phone
number so I will get this blurred so you
guys won't be seeing my phone number
okay is asking for the code I'm waiting
for the code after entering the OTP you
would be directed to this page that is
chat GPT and this is the Field Box where
you can write any query in the simple
natural language that would be English
and the chat jpt would answer your
questions and if we talk about chat JP
uh little bit information about chj that
it's an AI powered chatboard that has
been developed by open Ai and the
chatboard understands natural language
and responds in a humanlike manner it is
based on GPT 3.5 which is a language
model and the chatboard was unveiled as
a prototype on November 30 2022 while
announcing the chatboard open a wrote on
its announcement page that we have
trained a model called chat jpt which
interacts in a conversational way the
dialogue format makes it possible for
chat jpd to answer followup questions
admit its mistake challenge incorrect
premises and reject inappropriate
requests so now we will talk about the
chat jity so CH jbt is an AI powered
chatboard that has been developed by the
artificial intelligence and it's been
researched by the company open Ai and
the chatboard understands natural
language and responds in a humanlike
manner it is based on GP 3.5 which is a
language model the chatboard was
unveiled as a prototype on November 30
2022 while announcing the chatboard
openi wrote on its announcement page
that we have trained a model called Chad
JP which interacts in a conversational
way the dialogue format makes it
possible for chat JP to answer followup
questions admit its mistake challenge
incorrect premises and reject
inappropriate
requests so this is J and it's been
boing all the developers around the
globe so now we'll start with automating
Excel with the help of chat jpt and with
the help of Python
language so first
we will create a folder and see the
Excel files with which we will use
Python and with the help of chat
jpt we will automate
them so first we'll create a folder for
our project and we'll create in Python
projects and name it
as automate Excel
using chat
jpt and inside this we will open the
command
prompt and now we will open any idink so
that we'll write a request to chat GPT
and he'll answer us with the suitable
code and that code we will copy paste
into our idle and run it if it gives any
error we will copy paste the error same
to the chat jpt and as I know he answers
them so here we will open our ideally
and for that we are writing a command
that is code space period and that will
open our ideally that is Visual Studio
world now we have open our ID and first
we'll create a file
here or first we'll see our Excel files
on which we will do the
Automation and for that it'll get back
to our
folder and here we have the number
folder in which we have two files that
is CSV files phone number and phone
number two
and other we have the sales folder and
in that we have the date of the sales of
the Year
2022 so we'll use these files sales and
the number so we'll cut them
and get to a
folder and inside the number file no uh
we'll start with
sales first we do the automation with
the sales
files so we will open the sales folder
and inside that we'll create a file that
would be the py
file and the first automation we would
be doing is concatenating all the files
in a single Excel file we have the files
from January to December that is the
sales files so we'll concatenate them
and ask the chat jpt to write the code
to con sorry to concatenate all
these so for
that we name the file as conate
only
inate _ data
py so now we will give the command to
the chat
jpd so here is a chat jpd and here we
will write a command for it that would
be I have 12 Excel
files and I want to concatenate
them and we'll also mention the name
named
January spelling January is this only
but we'll check with the file
CH and then we have February
and moving
on so on we have till
December so we have all these 12 files
and now we'll command him to use
Python to concatenate the data inside
the 12 XEL files into one
file
so this is our Command and it's in the
simplest natural language that is the
English language so we'll just press
enter okay it shows us that an error
occurred if the this so for this thing
we'll just copy the open a link and
paste it here and open it as the chat
jpt is seeing a huge
traffic sometimes it
shows these
errors so he's verifying us whether we
are a robot or
not so we will agree with the
chat and answer it questions
here
it's asking again okay now we are clear
with the chity and we'll paste our
Command here and press
Center and here you can see that it has
started answering our question that you
can use the pandas library in Python to
read in the data from each of the Excel
files and use the concat function to
combine the data from all the and one
data frame here's an example of how you
want use
okay he going in a very right
Manner and he has imported pandas and
then create a data and using the for
[Music]
Loop he is going through all the months
reading the Excel file and appending
okay
done and result he has concatenated but
he has not created the X file where we
can see all the data and he has also not
printed it so what we want so first
we'll
see what does this code do as I have
seen so it will concatenate but it has
not created the Excel file in which we
can see all the data so we have copied
the code we will paste it
here save it and run
it
and most important thing you have to
import the pandas library and if you
have not installed it please install it
in the command prompt with the command
pip install pandas or you can use it in
the
terminal
okay it has not found the january.
XLS okay so JN UA are
by look sping we'll
see what error it
expects we'll save this and run once
again so we'll just copy the error and
write it back to chat JP and see
how does it
respond okay is seeing is indicating
that the P library is unable to find the
Excel file you trying to read in based
on the error message look like the files
are not located in the same directory as
the python
script okay we'll see that but we have
the python script and the
library and
same
folder
yeah
concate py and we'll check once again
here let data py
yeah they are in the same folder and why
we have this
error Okay so
so theor is we have opened our
IDE
in the automated Excel using chat jpd
folder and currently we are in sales
folder so it is not
recognizing the
directory so what we'll
do we'll copy all these
files copy these sales
files and paste it
here
now now we will run the port that chat
JP provided
us okay uh yeah it has run
successfully exed successfully okay
we'll try once again we kill the
terminal save it and run it
again now we'll see yeah it has executed
successfully uh but the thing is it has
not converted it
into a single Excel file for that we
will
write you forgot
to
create the
concatenated file as we also haven't
mentioned in our
Command
specifically so we have to be specific
with our commands
Also let's
see yeah after conting the data frame to
export to a Excel file we can just write
this
command and index equal to false here
okay and he is giving all the
explanations so you can just read them
correct I apologize for the weite to
create a new Excel file that contains
data you can use the 2core XEL method of
the data frame here is an example of how
you could do this okay cre a new Excel
file named concore data. xlsx in the
same directory as your python script and
it will contain the concatenated data
form from all of the original Excel file
you could also use a 2core CSU method to
save the data frame in CSV format yeah
we can do that
also okay
we make the xlsx
file and just beneath
it
yeah C part
two okay uh we don't need any path we'll
just do it here
only here result.
2XL data
xlsx so we'll save this and run
it
and is showing that it has executed
successfully and yeah outside the sales
folder we will close it you can see that
it has created the concatenated data
xlsx so for that we'll move here yeah it
has created it
here we'll open
it and first I will show you what these
files
contain so every file have the entry of
around th000 every file has
1,000
entries so the conate file should have
around
12,000 so this is the concore data and
if we go
beneath yeah we can
see
2000 and it's yeah it says it has
concatenated all the data so yeah chat
GPT responded and we have to precise
with the commands what we are writing in
English as it has not mentioned to
convert it into Excel file now when we
have written it again it has done that
now moving on we will do the second
Automation and for that we'll move back
to our ideally and the next automation
we will be doing would be that we will
be using the sum and the average
function to all the files that is from
January to December files and
we'll use sum and average function I'll
show show you where we will
use so it's going
data so we'll open the August
file and here you can see the quantity
in the Ed
column so we'll average down the
quantity so what is the average per
customer
and in the J column we have the total
code cost so we will add all the cost in
all the files this is the August file
from January to December we will do in
column H the average for the quantities
and column J we'll do the sum of the
total amount per customer and we'll get
it printed at the last column that would
be we have the th000
entries it's going till
h11 so we would get it printed on
h12 and the sum we would get it printed
on
J12 okay so moving on we'll close this
files we will get back to a chat jpd and
give him a command that I have 12 Excel
files and we'll tell him that we have
named
them
January then we
have
February
then we have till
December and
now we want you to use
Python
to
apply the sum
formula the sum formula and the average
formula so the sum formula would be
applied from J2 to
j101 let see okay we have Clos file yeah
what I remember some formula
from J2 2 J 1 0 1 okay and and the
average
function and now we want him to use the
formula from H2 to
h11 okay and that would be in all the
Excel
files and we want him to write the
results in the cells and that would be
J12 and
h12
respectively so we have to be precise
with the commands and we have an error
here uh that is done and yeah it's all
done now I'll just give this command to
chat jpt and see how it answers use the
pan library in Python to read okay and
perform the sum and average calculations
good and then write the results back to
the same file here is an example of how
you could do this yeah we writing in the
same
file okay we are importing friend PD and
running a loop for all the months we
have read all the Excel files one by one
and we are taking the
cell one and I location and doing the
sum and doing the mean of the edge
column yeah it's
good
excent yeah I think it would do our
job so we'll copy this and create a new
file and name it
as some
py and inside this we will paste the
code that our GPT has provided
us and we'll run this and it has
executed successfully okay no uh we got
an error that
is okay okay okay it has made the
mistake
okay
it okay we'll just see what
query we WR I have 12 X Files name Jan
to De and use Python to apply the Su
formula from j22
j11 and the average formula from H2 to
h11 in all the files and write the
results
okay
done uh we would be a little
specific this Cs
j102 and
okay okay okay okay yeah we once again
submit it if we did it
get okay yeah now he has used the
open yxl Library that's
good yeah that would be working for
us let's
see what he will provide to
us
yeah she active
and
okay
okay yeah
think uh it can serve the purpose but
first we'll run it so he is giving us
the explanation for what he has written
this code that is this code will apply
the Su formula to the range j22 j101 and
the average formula to the range H2 to
h101 in all the Excel files the results
will be written in
J12 and h12 respectively it is important
to note that this code will overwrite
the original file so that it's
recommended to make a backup okay we
don't need that and we have backup in
the sales folder also so you can also
the read XEL and 2core XEL function from
P
okay so we'll try this
code
uh it is not return return to import OS
and guys uh you have to install all
these libraries open pyxl I have already
installed them you can search on the
browser that open pyxl installation
Python and it would be directed to pypi
tocom that's the official website for
the particular libraries and there you
can see the command that would be the
PIP install and the particular command
for the module name
uh it is showing that it has run
successfully so we'll just see if it has
done its job or
not and in the AIL file we have in the
Hedge column that is the average of the
Hedge column that for the items and in
the J column we have the total sum of
the amount of the customers yeah
the query has run successfully Jad jpt
has provided us with the perfect code
heads off to the J jbt and moving on now
we'll do some other
automations and
now what we can
do uh we have other files that is phone
number and phone number
two and what it
contains
it contains the phone
numbers so what we could do
is we could add the plus 91 extension
that is the country code for India we
will ask chat jity to add the country
code plus 91 to both the
files so I'll close these
files and
first we'll copy them and paste in
our root directory so we don't get any
error and
we'll change the
slide
name instead of
hyphen we will add the
underscore
okay now we'll move back to chat jpd and
write a
command and these files are CSV files no
xlsx
file yeah these are CSV files both the
files are CSV files other files are xlsx
files okay so for that we'll write the
command to chat jity
that I have two
files
uh with to CSV extension
and they are
named phone
underscore number and the second was
named phone underscore number underscore
2 okay so we have told the J jpt that we
have two files and now we'll tell him to
use
Python to add the country
code add
the
country code plus
as string
prefix and that would be adding as a
string prefix else it would only show 91
it won't show plus so we'll see if Chad
jpd understand that or not as string
prefix in both the CSV files
with column name that was
phone
okay now we'll just press
enter and wait for a chat jity to answer
this
query and we'll see how it
responds you can use the p as library to
well okay and the prefix to the phone
numbers and modify data
okay do this okay
[Music]
okay
the now
weing
andone it's adding as type string okay
it has understood that and to
CSV then this code will in both of us
here I think this will
work we have copied the code this code
will in both CS files and the plus time
string to the phone numbers and write
the modifi data back to the Cs files
it's important to know that this will
override the original file so it's
recomended to make a backup with the
original
okay uh you could also use the apply
function to add the Prix to the phone
number in the column
okay okay yeah uh we can do this also
the lambdaa
function and that's this will also do a
job
first we'll see
this and we will create a
file for this Automation and name it as
country code. py okay and we'll paste
the code
here and run it for you guys but showing
that it has executed
successfully uh yeah it has executed
successfully so we'll
just go back to our
files and
see whether the go+ 91 as a prefix or
not here the numbers okay the file scod
only 91 as the column it's still in the
number
format it
hasn't converted into string format uh
we see the second code
also
like yeah it has converted X into string
okay Lambda X we'll
see it's working or
not like it has worked uh and the issue
is we
have change the files permission red
okay we have opened a file we'll close
it don't save
save this and run it
again now it shows it has executed
successfully we'll open the
files and now if we
see it is showing yeah uh now it has
added 2
91s uh so no issues uh the thing is
first we have to transform it into the
string format and then we can add plus
91 as a string to that
string so chat JP misses with the
slightest implementation the
code now moving on uh we'll see this
command later if you want to see how we
can add plus 91 I will tell you how to
write that code
okay so now moving on we will do another
Automation and you would be glad to know
that Chad jpt improves the existing code
like uh in the first automation it has
concatenated but it hasn't converted the
concatenated file like it hasn't created
that file it had created the file when
we have returned to it that you forgot
to create that file so chat jpd it
modulates the existing code
also and moving
on
now uh in
any okay we open the concatenated _ data
not
xlsx and inside this okay we have the
product line so what we'll do is we will
change
the name of the electronic assesses to
electronic equipments and home and
lifestyle to
Lifestyle now we'll automate this
process and we can do this automation
all the files also from January to
December so we'll do that only
okay now here
we will command
is Okay now we'll command the chat jpt
that using
python I
trate
through all the Excel
files in
the directory so we are asking him to
iterate through all the Excel files in
the directory and we will ask him to
replace what was electronic
asss electronic
accessories see the spelling
notc accessories
okay yeah electronic accesses with
electronic
equipments and we'll also ask
him
equipments okay we'll do equipment only
and home and lifestyle we have choosen
yeah
and home and
lifestyle
and and change it with
only
lifestyle okay so using python we are
iterating through all the Excel files
and changing these
uh that would be in each Excel file so
we have to be specific with a written
language and now we'll save the modified
workbook
in we'll create another folder and in
that we will save the
files
okay save
the
modified
file in
the
output
folder and if the folder is not created
we'll ask him to create
it
okay then and create
one
hold add it
in okay I don't know why I'm saving this
so I have written the command I will
press enter so that J jpd can process it
and give us the code for
that so it's showing us sorry that was
show showing us uh you can use the OS
Library toate through all the Excel
files and directory the pandas library
to read in the files and make the
changes and to save the modified files
okay here's an example of how you could
do
this now here we imported OS Pand as PD
and it has written the code we'll copy
that this code will liate through all
the Excel files in the current directory
replace electronic accessories with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle in the data
frame and then save the modified files
in the output folder if the sorry if the
output folder doesn't exist the script
will create
it you would also use replace function
to replace values in the column
okay this will WR it through all the
cells in each of the Excel sheet and
replace electronic accessories with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle if the cell
value is equal to the respective string
okay we have copied a
code and now we will create a
file
and name it as it trade.
py paste the code here and run it for
you
guys the code has been executed
successfully now we'll
see
we open all the files not all but yeah
we'll open
some that was the previous electronic
access okay so it hasn't changed in
this okay we will open another
file and see if we code the changes in
that or not
that also States the electronic
accessories so it
hasn't done its
job so move back to
jpd and use this code if it functions
else we'll write back to the chat
jpd
okay
just a second I the we are using the
replace and F in
ex okay so for here we have to import
the
OS
done load uncore
book and for
that import this
and
it and close this
files
okay now we'll
see if we got our solution or
not no it's showing electronic accessies
and home and lifesty so chat jpd
doesn't got the code to change
them so we'll ask him another time and
with a different language this
time Al I don't think it has created the
output
folder it has oh
sorry I'm really sorry what I have done
is my
mistake those were the original files
and we have the product line here and we
have electronic accessories
here and that should be
equipments okay uh we have electronic
assess and
lifestyle let me see my
command
okay I have asked him to change
electronices with electronic equipment
and home lifestyle with lifestyle so it
has changed only
lifestyle let
see
okay
okay uh the E here is small we'll update
that in the
code you can write this back to chat jpt
also but yeah first we do
this what are i
showing
note has executed
successfully
okay in the output folder we have the
this number
accessories that's with the capital okay
okay okay okay so this code is giving us
error we'll see the last code we'll copy
that
and
try to use
this close the terminal and run it
again it has executed successfully now
we'll see the
file whether it has changes or not it
has not now we'll ask the chat
jpd what have you done
brother using python I through all the
Excel files in the Dory and replace
electronic assess with electronic
equipment and home and lifestyle with
lifestyle okay H Exel file save the
modified modifies
[Music]
file
okay will ask the same thing once again
to
him and with this electronic accessories
oh
sorry and save the mod ified
file output folder and get the folder it
doesn't exist
okay
okay the same the
mov let see once
again
close these
files has executed successfully now
we'll open
it and now we can see that it has
changed to electronic
equipment electronic
equipment yeah now it has executed
successfully maybe there would be an
error with us while copying it as we
have also created the output folder but
we forgot to see in that folder maybe
that could be the error from our
side now we are done with the changing
of the column names uh the cell names
that was electronic assess to electronic
equipments and home and lifestyle to
Lifestyle now we'll do the next
automation
for that first we'll open an Exel
file uh this was in the output
folder we get back to our main directory
and open the file
July and
here here we will filter the Excel file
for gender that is we'll select gender
as female and with the unique values in
column
City and we'll extract the data from
column A to q that would be the whole
data and for each Unique city value
we'll create a new Excel file for each
City and that will contain data only for
that City and for females only and after
that we'll save this file in a folder
named City so we'll give this command to
chat jpt
and here you can also specify the module
you want chat JP to use for the
particular command here we will be
commanding the chat jpt to use the
pandas module and for that we'll write
the command note command in the natural
language we'll give this command to the
chat
jbd and for that we'll write using
Python and
pandas
filter
the okay we will just pick a single
Excel file or we can pick the
concatenated file that is concatenated
uncore
data filter
the
concatenated underscore
data do Xcel
SX
Excel
file and that would be for gender
female and by
the unique values in column
City okay first we'll give the
command by the unique
values in the
colum
City and after that we want to extract
the data from colum a2q that is the
whole
sheet extract the
data from the
column A2 q and for each Unique city
value
for each
Unique
city
value now we will extract the data and
now we'll create a new Excel file so for
that also we'll give the command to J
jpd and we'll write create a new Excel
file and that would be for each
City
okay so we'll write create a
new Excel
file for each
City
containing
data only for
that
City and for
females
okay and save this file in
the city
folder and if
it not being there chat jpt can create
the folder for that
also okay City folder
and naming the each file with the city
name
Okay naming each
file after
the
corresonding
city
okay now if
the city folder that is we have written
the small City
okay if the city folder doesn't
exist then create
it before saving the
files
okay now we have given this command to
the chat jpt and it has responded us
with you can use the Panda's Library as
we already mentioned to use that to
readin
theore data. xlsx file and filter the
data for gender female group the data by
the unique values in the city column and
extract the data from the specified
columns for each group and here is an
example so we have put the
code we'll wait till Chad jpd
continues
and we can see that the chat GPD has
completed
and we will copy this
code
open just
seeed
female City make the D City and for City
Group in female dataout group by okay
City and you could also use the Asen
method to filter the data frame for
female gender okay first we'll see
this and
for that we will create filter.
py and run the
code it has been executed successfully
so now you'll see that the city folder
has been created or
not I'm not able to see the city
folder okay it's been
created so we see okay it's been
created man it's still
empty so we'll give
time
okay V quote an
error okay okay we'll pass this error to
J J first and after that we'll see
what's wrong with
this you are so theor message you saying
is ining that the column name specified
in the list are not present in the data
frame it's likely that the actual column
names in the data frame are different
than the ones you specified in the
list okay just see the
list that is concatenated
data go
back and see that is
A2
okay it's still
R okay we made a little mistake
here so we'll
just change our
Command yeah this is it and instead of Q
now we'll write R and save and submit
now see what it
would what it would generate for
us we'll close
this
okay let going F inel files filter the
data for femes group the data by the
unique values in the city column create
and extract the data from the column A
to R for each Unique city name and then
create a new Excel file for each City
containing data only for that City and
for females files will be sa in the city
folder naming each file after the
corresponding City
okay it's done now we'll copy this
code and paste it here and
see whether this code works for us or
not so it's been executed
successfully now we have moved to the
set okay it's executing so we'll give
time to the code
let it do it so yeah it's been executed
successfully okay so there were three
cities that was
M Na and
Yangon and if I show you the
data you could
see there see three cities and it has
created the Excel files with the name of
the Cities only the unique cities and it
has extracted the data for the gender
female now we'll see those
files close
this and
back in the city
folder could see the m city and the data
is just for the
females so this automation works well
with J
jbt now moving on we will do one more
Automation and that would be to use
Python to identify what is the count of
each payment
mode so for
that I will just get you aware of the
payment modes in our sheet and we'll do
this automation on the concatenated data
sheet only
so this is the payment column and you
can see the mode of payments that is
ewallet cash credit card and these are
repeating so we will use Python to
identify what is the count of each
payment mode from column M column and
sorry and that is from this sheet only
and then we'll create a new sheet and
name it as count. xlsx and write the
count against each payment method so
we'll give this command to our chat
gbt and ask him to write the code for
our
automation so we writing use Python to
identify use Python to
identify what is the count
of E
each payment
method
from column and the column was n from
column n and that was in
concatenated con
cated
underscore data do xlsx
sheet
and create an new
named count do
xlsx
and write the
count
against each payment
method
okay now we have given this command to a
chat jpd and we'll see what it offers to
us you can use the Pand library to read
okay that's the same value counts
function to get the count of each method
okay and you can use the two XEL method
to the data frame to write the count to
a new sheet okay that's good and here is
imported the Panda's library and create
the DF variable in which he has read the
con file and used counts function with
the payment method
and columnal to payment me okay the
column name is
payment not payment method I think it
would
generate an error for
us
[Music]
so spyon of each one method from column
n and we will
specify column M and that is named
payment as it has used payment method
here you can
see that it has used the column name as
payment method so we'll specify
this we have to be very specific with
our commands for these automations for
simple task you can use Simple language
like no complex sentences or you have to
mention every detail but for these
automations you have to use
them now our chat jpd is working with
this and mostly he will deliver us with
the perfect code I hope
so okay
uh has red and the value ground and it
has
exported
reset also the group by function to
group the data the payment method and
use the
size
okay okay we'll see
this and
here we will create a file as count.
py and in this file we'll paste the code
delivered us by the chat
JP we
have executed it it's being executed
we'll wait for
that it's been executed
successfully so we have mve back to our
folder and we have to look for
F count file now yeah count
file is this the no it's okay yeah it's
showing us the mode of payments that is
ewallet cash credit card and the number
of
usage yeah 4
48,3 12 yeah it's 12,000 that was the
whole entry of the
concore data do xlsx so we have done
with this Automation and now we'll do
one last
Automation and first
we'll close all these
files okay and moving back to our jat
GPT and now
we will do we will rename all the 12
Excel files that was January February to
December and we'll add the
word uh Car Sales just before the month
name that would we will just add the
prefix before the month name and for
that we'll give the command to the chat
GP in the natural language and here only
we will change it in the main directory
only as we have the copy of all these
files so for this we'll write the
command use
Python
rename all the 12 Excel
files
named
January
February
until
December okay and that is present in my
directory and what we have to do is we
have
to add uh the
word will add Car Sales
okay car Sals
in front
of
each in front
of each file
name
okay so what it will do is Car Sales
underscore January Car Sales uncore
February and so on so we'll wait for the
chat jpd you can use the OS library to
iterate through all the Excel files in
then use the W store rename function
okay to rename the files here is an
example of how you could do this go to S
and we have the
months
okay
this code will iterate through all the
Excel files in the current directory and
add carels in front of each file
name and those files would be those only
the months and good it's using the glow
module and you could also use the GL mod
okay that's the second
code it's the even
okay but we'll go with OS
first and get back to our ideally and
name the file as rename
dopy and here we'll paste the
code and run
it it's been executed we'll move back
yeah you could see that car sales have
been added to all the
files and with that we have done with
our
automations and if you want you can also
submit your code to chat GPT and ask it
to add commands to your code so that it
could explain you what that line does or
what that function does it would explain
very tediously and if you want you can
also try chat gbd to automate many
office
tasks you can automate PowerPoint for
that and do many more tasks with
J enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment and post-graduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box during our
childhood we have heard the fictional
stories of robots taking over various
household courses making the lives of
humans easy peasy but if you're not
aware then these fictional stories are
turning into reality though not in the
form of physical robots but yes in the
form of computer programs and apps with
the help of artificial intelligence and
machine learning Technologies confused
let me introduce to you to Chad GPD a
pre-trained model that interacts with
user in a conversational way Chad G
is founded by open Ai and the model is
based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chat GPT chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat GPT in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chat GPT will play an important tool in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by open AI option one chat GPT 1
option 2 chat gpt2 option three chat GPT
3 and option four none of the above let
us know your answer in the comment
section below and if your answer is
correct you will get a hard from Simply
learn as we discussed earlier chat jpt
is the application of artificial
intelligence and machine learning we
know that SEO rankings depends on
various factors like on page
optimization off page optimization and
more while using chat GPT we will
understand how chat GPT helps in various
Su ranking parameters and reduces the
manual work so without any further delay
let's begin so to begin with let's open
chat
GPT we need to go to new chat which is
already open
here let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SE optimized uh blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog so before
that let's choose what kind of blog we
want to create I really love traveling
so let's try to create a travel blog so
for the travel blog we will find some
good
keywords
that so here you can see we are getting
some suggestions for the travel
destinations we can choose any of
them okay so here we got around seven of
the result
so let's try to get something for
Japan suggest me good keywords to create
a
blog on
Japan
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords okay so it
is it is showing that these keywords
cover a range of topics related to
Japanese culture history food and
more uh out of these I guess we can
start with the places here are few
places like Mount
Fiji Tokyo and everything so let's try
to create a
blog on top 10 places to visit in
Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in
Japan
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in
Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword
recommendations and it is also
suggesting that by using these keyword
words our content will be more dis
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for for for SE for search
rankings write me a Blog on top
10 places to
visit in
Japan so the idea is we will try to
write a blog and after which we will try
to uh optimize the blog with respect to
the keyword top 10 places to visit in
Japan and we will also uh see whether
all the SEO practices can be easily
applicable or not using chat
GPT so here you can see we are are
getting a Blog with a introduction with
top 10 places and probably what I expect
is to get a good conclusion out of
it also like uh uh chat jpt provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want uh to several number of words
like if this Blog has 2,000 or 5,000
words you can just ask chat GPD to
reduce it to 2,000 or th000 words
also so here you can see that before
when we search there were only one
liners about these destinations these
places in Japan and now we are getting a
detail about all the 10
places
definitely we have targeted this blog
for for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords to increase its
reach suggest few more
relevant keywords for my
block okay so we are getting some more
keywords
here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this
blog as a good title helps the user to
click on your content and it uh
increases the possibility to get more
and more
traffic so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which is somewhat similar
to what we are
expecting
at the best
suitable title in my
blog okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss okay so here we got title for a
Blog but here we can see there is a
slight limitation that it is suggesting
the title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my
blog for the
keyword top
10 places to visit in Japan top 10
places to visit in Japan
with an
optimized
title
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to add the title in the
blog
optimize blog for
the
keyword top 10 places to visit
and
okay so here it is showing the relevant
suggestions so maybe there is a
slight ambiguity in the query that's why
it's not representing us the correct
results we are going to optimize our
blog using all these
factors visit in
Japan
again these are the
suggestions
let's try to implement these one by
one add headings H1
H2 in the above blog
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and
H2 and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in
H2 H1 and H2 tags are some of the
practices in the on page optimization
which uh helps the search engine boards
to understand that this is something
important really important uh for the
page and they pick up these hints for uh
getting your uh page
rank so yes it is
implemented
e
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2
implementations let's try to get some
inter l s for this blog interlinks have
their own importance as interlinking
your blog with other pages of your
website or your blogging Pages this will
help you to gain the traffic from other
pages to your blog and uh uh putting the
traffic from your blog to other pages of
your
website also it helps the search engine
birs to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure
also so
suggest me
few
interlinks for the above
block so yes definitely these are the
relevant and uh expected links we are
getting so if you have any of these uh
blog pages in your uh website or if you
have created any of these blogs earlier
do Interlink
it vir of
above can I use in my blog so definitely
there are number of suggestions but if
you want to choose one how can you pick
the one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for
this
okay so it is not only suggesting that
we can use all of the above
but it is also showing the significance
of
interlinking okay moving
ahead so till now we have optimized our
blog for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the uh top 10 places to
visit in Japan we have added headings
and we have tried to get some of the
good Interlink suggestions to add
interlinks in our blogs which are some
of the good practices of the on page
optimizations so next moving ahead in
another onpage optimization technique is
let's try to get a cover image for this
blog so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog
page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to the diversity of
the country panormic view of Tokyo
Skyline the beautiful image of Kyoto's
tradition Temple Mount Fuji hiroshima's
peace Memorial
Park so we will try to pick one and uh
see if we are getting any image
idea let's take for Mount
Fuji suggest me the image idea for
Mount so let's see we have seen in
generic for all now let's see for the uh
image suggestion specific to M
Fuji okay definitely it is showing uh
number of suggestions for the specific
Mount Fuji
image so if you are looking to create
another block for Mount Fuji then these
ideas are easy to take
up
optimize the
mount f G image for my
blog here are some tips to optimize the
image for Mount Fuji for my blog which
are they're showing that the image
should be high
resolution then a clear
subject definitely if you have a large
image uh large file size it really gets
difficult to load and the page load
speed will increase so if you have a
large file size the image should be
compressed without reducing its quality
image
quality we should have descriptive file
names and all
tags
okay so let's try to get a very good
file name and all tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the uh when
considered as a user
so get
me
good
image title
and ALT tag
for Mount fug
image so there is importance for ltag as
search engines other Bots uh they won't
able to identify the image directly so
Al tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is
about so yes it is showing not one but
number of suggestions for all the Mount
Fuji recommendations which we got
earlier so we will try to choose one and
get a caption for
it
write a
good
caption
for for the
image seic
Fuji Five Lakes
Region so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions
here I guess this caption is quite long
so let's try to reduce it to 40
words reduce the
above caption
to not even 40 let's do it in 20 20
words okay this one is
better
now let's try to get the image if there
is
any
choose the
mount fui image for my
blog choose image it should not I
repeat choose the perfect
illustration
for Mount
Fuji image for
my
block so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us the suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image if it really works we can get
it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat
GPT we can only get the recommendations
to choose the image and yes it is
showing some suggestions of un unsplash
pixels or Shuttle stock to download the
image so we can uh really navigate to
these websites and download some of the
required image for our blog
so we we have uh completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your
website or your blog
page suggest me suggest video ideas
for the
above
blog
okay so if we are getting few of the
video
ideas
which of the above idea is best match
for my blog let's try to extract anyone
from the above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll
choose for
or again we will continue with Mount
Fuji
only provide video optimization
optimization
ideas
video
optimizations
for Mount fui video for above
blog okay so it is showing us some of
the suggestions which uh which we can
can Implement for a video as we do not
have any video here we can just take
these recommendations and optimize
whatever the video of our
choice so let's take the thumbnail
suggestions in our next query uh if it
can suggest us a Mount Fuji uh thumbnail
uh image suggestion uh and the video tag
suggestion
right
suggest
me
good thumbnail idea for Mount
FG
video thumbnails have the Major Impact
for any videos it is the only thing
uh I repeat
thumbnails thumbnails are one of the
important factors which encourages the
user to click on your video and watch
the complete
video so definitely having a good
thumbnail will help your content to
rank so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our
block so we are done with the thumbnail
ideas after which we will get we will
try to get video tags so for getting
video tags let's get for all of
them find
me
video tags
for the all of
above
thumbnail
suggestions tags are important to help
the user to get your videos in the
search
list like if someone uh uh types Mount
Fuji in the search box and if the Mount
Fuji keyword is or a tag is added to
your video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly user may click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important um on page optimization
practices now let's try to get backlinks
which is one of the most famous off page
optimization
technique above
block
okay so it is
showing some of the link
suggestions so basically back links are
the
links which points from another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website so getting backlink uh is
one of the trust factors in the search
engin eyes that your content is really
unique and more of more users wants to
read it and share it with another uh
users so the search engines by by by
these search engines understand that
your content is really good and it is
worth of ranking so definitely getting a
good backlink from a very good authority
websites is uh fruitful for your
content so let's try to
get which
pages on web are
suitable to get backlinks for my
blog so here we are getting some of the
ideas or suggestions that which Pages we
can choose to get a backlink so here is
industry specific websites so if you are
writing a travel blog there should be a
travel trip ad uh Trip Advisor like
websites uh which are showing more of
the trip oriented or bookings related
oriented for travel or uh
destinations there are few of the
directories okay government websites
which are the tourism websites in our
case right now
blogging websites and social media
platforms which can be relevant to the
current scenario which we are using here
so let's check how can we get
backlinks from
the
above
recommendations for my blog
okay guest
posting broken link
building okay these are some of the
backlink building methods which we are
getting so that we can find one and get
one of the black uh I
repeat so these are these are some of
the backlink building strategies which
we are getting in the recommendation so
we can Implement any of these to get a
backlink for our
blog let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the
recommendations or the ideas to get back
links for the from the blogging
site so we can Implement these ideas and
it it may be possible to get
backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catch a metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only uh data
which is U which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get
one
s create
SEO
optimize meta title and
meta description for my
blog so we are getting some suggestions
here top 10 places to visit in Japan
discover the best place to visit in
Japan top 10 destinations definitely we
have your top 10
destinations see also we are getting
some of the notes
that it is good to have meta title less
than 60 characters so if if it is more
than 60 character you may get the dot
dot part and the title will not be
clearly visible in the search result
page so let's try to again optimize The
Meta title and meta description for top
10 places to visit in
Japan
description for the key
word top
10 places
to visit in
Japan
okay so we can use any of the one the
one we have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our
content so one of the technical SEO
factor which we are going to see here is
get in the URL
recommendation uh URLs are the important
factor uh it helps the search engine
boards to understand about the page as
the URL is the first thing search
engines may be visiting to come to your
page so uh it is a good practice to have
the keyword in your url rather than
having some of the abrupt characters
like x a r atate these kind of stuffs in
the link so let's
create the URL
suggestions suggest
me SEO
optimized URL for the above
block see so here we are getting top 10
places to visit in Japan which is
definitely our blog and as a keyword we
are using it to optimize our content and
it is placed in the URL so this URL is
completely
correct also these kind of suggestions
are very good for the newbies in the uh
search engine domain as they will
definitely understand why and what we
are doing to optimize our
pages so next moving ahead with some of
the non-technical aspects which may
impact which may definitely impact to
bring the traffic so let's try to get
some of the sharing suggestions
like which
platforms should
I
repeat which sharing
options should I add in
my
block so out of the mentioned uh sharing
buttons we can add any of them adding at
least three to four sharing buttons is
considered to be really good out of
which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common WhatsApp Shares are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common so you can choose any of these to
add it in your
blogs D
commenting
on my
blog
impact
on traffic source so here we are taking
the suggestion that will this help or
not again this is again linked to the
back links that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backing for their web and this is
again uh going in symbotic way like if
they are asking for a a back link for
from your blog you can even ask from
them so this is the way of or a part of
a communication to get a back links as
well can you find
the
duplicate
content in above log so duplicate
content is a concept where search
engines you you must be aware that
search are really in love with the
unique content so having a duplicate
content may
really uh affect your uh uh web
visibility and it is possible that your
page may get dead after a
time so plagarism is not at all allowed
uh when you're creating a Content it is
not suggested in any
case Okay so it is not uh able to uh
chat GP is not able to identify the
duplicate content however uh it is
suggesting us some of the tools like
copy scape or seliner to understand if
the content we are creating for our blog
is duplicate or
not and let's get some suggestions how
to
make content
unique just in case if someone is not
aware to create a unique
content we can get some of the tips
here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SE
that is 44 Pages 44 pages
are really not are not likely to get
search
because I
repeat let's try to see another another
aspect of technical
Su uh try to find some 44 pages on the
website
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find 44
Pages uh it is not possible for the chat
GPT to get one but we can use uh some of
the tools suggested like uh screaming
frog or Google search console where we
get the detailed report of the broken
links or 44 page PES that is the dead
pages of our
website so let's wrap up from the uh
view of the technical ESO
perspective let's consider one of the
scenario that we have published this
blog and how can we promote this blog to
reach more of the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer uh add it as a guest
post and Link back to this this blog
email marketing yes it is the most
trending technique to reach more of the
audiences P advertising
commenting content
syndication yes medium and Linkedin are
the very famous platforms for this
online
communities so you can you can
definitely uh try to be the member of
the online communities and forums where
you can just put up the link and the
members of your Niche may definitely
visit your content and share it with
others
also so yes we we have seen that uh
search for as as a perspective of search
engine optimization chat GPT is uh
helpful really really helpful to create
the in content Creation in optimizations
and many of the other
things today in an era of mobile devices
robots and social media content creation
is the most effective inbound marketing
strategy nearly 40% of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81% say their
company views content as a business
strategy original and highquality
content can help your company stand out
and attract new customers and help your
business grow on that note welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
are here with a fantastic video on chat
GPD for Content creation which will help
you create some compelling content on
your desired topics but before we get
started guys I have a question for you
is CH GP an application and is it
available on Android well let us know
the answer in the comments below so let
us understand what is chat GPT here now
content creation can be of any type such
as blogs podcast videos graphics and so
on but how do you create high quality
content with a few minutes in be worried
when we have chat GPT now even though
there are numerous AI writing tools for
Content creation chat GPT stands out
from the crowd due to its faster
response rate ease of use increased
productivity support for multiple
languages and other benefits now let's
try to understand what exactly chat GPT
is and how to create content from it now
generally chat GPT is an open AI trained
and developed model that works
conversationally chat GPT is capable of
systematically resolving all bugs while
providing detailed explanation for each
step it takes so in simple words CH GPT
is a tool that creates content for any
query chat GPT stands out among all the
other achievements of open AI so let us
now move ahead and understand how does
chat GPT work now chat GPT uses deep
learning techniques to generate
humanlike text which is based on a
machine learning model derived from the
large language model class now it is
trained on a massive Text data sets from
the internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chat GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a of writer or a group
of writers share their views on an
individual subject now there are variety
of categories for writing a Blog so
let's pick one for chat GPD here so as
you can see we have navigated into chat
GPD and let us now ask a simple question
about fot blocking now lately food blogs
are the most popular blogs that everyone
wants to write about so let's find out
what chat GPT has to say about it now
you can give any question to chat GPT
and it will answer so I'm just uh
writing a question here saying how
to start a foot blogging
carer so as you can see it is generating
the answer for us uh wait for it to
end well as you can see it is saying
that starting a food block can be a fun
and rewarding way to share your love of
food with others so it is showing us
some steps to get started in food
blogging career it is saying choose a
nishe choose a name and domain choose a
blogging platform create your blog
create high quality content and so on so
in this way chat GPT will automatically
generate the response for you based on
the questions that you are giving input
to it next we will see another question
on lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular uh entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in chat GPT as well
and see what it will show the answer so
let's uh give the question as how to
start Life
Style blogging in
India so it is giving the answer for us
guys so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interest so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
uh important points for us you order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your nishe choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on chat GPT has been
helping in various Fields like customer
support virtual assistant education
content generation language translation
research and information retrival
personal productivity entertainment and
more now talking about content creation
then chat GPT can prove a valuable tool
in idea generation writing enhancement
research and fact checking SEO
optimization and social media content
the power of AI has been overcoming
these days so without any further Ado
let's begin chat GPT can assist you with
content SEO or search engine
optimization in following ways number
one is keyword research chat GPT can
help you to identify the relevant
keywords and key phrases that are
commonly used in your industry or
required for your topic by discussing
your content with chat GPD you can
uncover valuable keywords to optimize
your content for search engines so let's
find some keywords to create content on
showes we will create a blog on shoes so
let's add query to chat
GPT
so here we got few suggestions we can
pick any of them if needed you can check
these keywords in any keyword research
tool to check their search volumes if
you require so let's choose this keyword
let's write a blog using chat GPT in 500
words on this
keyword
the next we have is content optimization
chat GPT can provide insights on how to
optimize content for better search
engine rankings it can suggest where to
include keywords naturally within your
content recommends heading structure and
advice on appropriate keyword density so
to the above created blog let's find the
optimization
so here we saw the number of
optimizations suggested by chat GPT for
our content the next we have is meta
tags and descriptions Chad GPT can help
you to generate compiling metatags and
descriptions that accurately represent
your content these elements are
important for search engines to
understand the topic of your content and
display relevant information in search
results so let's ask chat GPD to write a
creative meta descriptions meta title
and meta tags for this
blog
if needed we can rephrase these metad
descriptions and titles as per our
requirement by providing another query
the next trick to master SEO content
with chat GPT is content length and
quality chat GPT can guide you on the
ideal length of your content based on
the search engine algorithms and user
preferences it can help you to ensure
that your content is of high quality
engaging and informative which can
positively impact on your SEO ranking so
let's understand what can be the ideal
length of this shoe
blog as we have already written a 500
Words length of blog let's change it to
another one suggested by chat
GPD
interlinking and S side structure
chat GPT can provide suggestions on how
to structure your content and
incorporate inter links effectively
interlinking helps search engines to
navigate your website and understand the
relationship between different pages
boosting your overall SEO so let's get
few of the link recommendations for our
blogs on
shoes
the next one we have is user intent and
readability chat GPT can assist in
understanding user intent and optimizing
your content accordingly by discussing
potential user queries and preferences
you can create content that aligns with
what users are looking for enhancing its
relevance and readability so let's check
out if the readability of the given blog
or blog created by chat GPT is good or
not
you can also test some other content
with chat GPT to check whether its
readability is good or not while chat
GPT can provide a valuable guidance it's
important to remember that se is a
complex field and requires a holistic
approach it's advisable to combine chat
GPT suggestions with best practices
industry knowledge and ongoing SEO
strategies to achieve optimal results
enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment in post-graduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description
box
chat GPD is truly a fascinating
technology changing how we interact with
language it's the result of years of
research and development by open AI who
have trained the model on a massive
amount of Text data to create a machine
that can easily understand and generate
humanik text imagine you are a digital
marketer looking to make a big impact on
your next campaign CH GP can help you do
that Chad gbt uses natural language
processing or NLP which can assist you
in creating compelling humanik copy for
your website social media and email
marketing it can even generate product
descriptions and add copy that is
engaging and optimized for search
engines using chat GPT will save time
and increase your productivity allowing
you to focus on other important aspects
of your campaign and with its ability to
generate multiple text variations you
can test and Define your messaging to
find the perfect tone and language that
resonates with your target audience get
ready to revolutionize your digital
marketing game with the help of this
video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how CH GP can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10 fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open launched CH GP it has been
making waves in every field be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
openi the company behind the development
of jjpd and your options are option a
alen musk and Sam Altman option b Jeff
Bezos and SAA option C Mark Zuckerberg
and L page option D zma and masayoshi
Son drop your answer in the comment
section below but before we begin let me
ask you if you are aiming to get
certified in digital marketing and want
to build a career in digal marketing
then Unleash Your digital marketing
potential with simply learn get ahead of
the competition and of skill with simply
learns IM AMT gaziabad digital marketing
program learn from industry experts gain
handson experience with real world
projects and master inbound and outbound
marketing strategies to drive business
growth join our community of successful
Learners today and become a digital
marketing Pro in no time to learn more
about this digital marketing course
check the the link in the description
box below okay then let's get started
there are many uses of chat jpt in
digital marketing it's main USB is smart
human sounding content writing we can
command it to write content related to
marketing first on our agenda is an ad
copy there are various ways to go about
it but we must understand that no matter
how much content sounds like humans it
is still a piece of content written by
an AI so you have to give detailed and
precise queries to get the best results
let's start by giving it a basic command
like write and add
[Music]
copy as you can see it gave us random ad
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learn digital marketing Master
[Music]
course
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it
[Music]
longer and VOA it gave us was a long
version of that same content now let's
try to convert it into email newsletters
V digital marketers often send emails to
promote our products and services so
let's give it a query as can you convert
it to email
newsletters as you can see it has
generated an email with a subject line
and body that is enticing and engaging
to read we can also utilize chat GP to
correct grammar or change the tone of
the content for example let's enter a
new query what is
[Music]
Facebook it has given us a Jour overview
of Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase
it more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital
[Music]
marketing as you can see it has
completely replaced it and it is more
interesting to read it as well CH GPT
can also help with keyword research so
let's try it we will give give a query
as suggest more Search keywords for a
digital marketing course
[Music]
side and voila it has completed a work
we use to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a
few seconds you can request to write
blogs as well let's give it a query to
search for some keywords for the blog
suggest keywords to write a blog on
digital marketing
it gave us some keywords you can ask it
to reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords
[Music]
volume here we have some suggestions
let's pick a topic content writing and
ask it to write an article on content
[Music]
writing
here we have our article for the blog
let's use chat GPT to se optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta
[Music]
description here we have meta title and
meta description for this article we can
even requested to give us an SEO
optimized URL
link
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search
[Music]
results
here we have fully SE optimized article
with meta title and meta description
with a SE optimized URL chat GPD can
also be used to train your customer
service chat boards but we can discuss
the process in some other video chat gbt
is well vered with its content writing
capabilities it can even help you write
product marketing campaigns let's try it
with this query the query is write a
product marketing campaign for simply
learn digital marketing
courses
well jat JB has done it again this
campaign looks interesting and it will
be able to generate more leads for
simply Lars courses Chad JT can also be
used to write scripts for YouTube videos
let's give it a query as write a script
for 5 minute YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
courses
[Music]
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if
you're a content creator and you don't
know how to to approach other content
creators for a collaborative video then
chat GP can help you with that it can
help you writing collaboration emails as
well my next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital
[Music]
marketing since my last query was
related to Simply learn chat GP assured
that I work for simply learn and I wrote
a customer collaboration email that
looks professional plus easy to read and
understand now let's open the chart GPD
and check let's refresh this I have
already opened my chart GPD you can just
log in it and then you're good to go so
let's say hello and
see so it's working completely fine
right now okay so what will we do today
is we'll open our Visual Studio code I
have created one folder which is
Tailwind it's an empty folder you can
just see that so in that folder We'll
add the Tailwind so first let's ask the
chat GPT to help us install or set up
the Tailwind so I'll
write
please set up
the relevant
let's
see
okay it's asking us to install node.js
first and then it's asking us to check
the version of
that
okay it's saying to install these new
Pro pixel JavaScript
module to add these component in the CSS
file so this is saying to add this in
the CSS file
okay
[Music]
so let's check whether it is telling us
something useful or
not post CL Class Auto
fixer
okay
okay now simultaneously let's
check the table
website how to install
this so here it's saying to install this
command NP install D tailin CSS and then
in it in that project then it's saying
to configure the template part to add
this to your dilin configure file then
it's saying to create a folder input.
GSS and then just start the process
so as of
now chat GPT has not given us the
correct answer it's correct but not up
to the mark as you can clearly see the
commands that are given on the Tailwind
docss official
website uh so according to me many
people think that uh because of char apt
the uh so many jobs of the developers
are in the risk
because chat jpt can create websites all
of the stuff so I don't think so
according to me it's not that good it's
very good for the uh helping any
developer purpose uh but it's not that
good but let's see we are in this
together so let's just open the visual
studio code and install our twin now
we'll ask it to create so many other
things so let's see whether it can
create that or not so I have opened my
terminal so many people also comment us
uh that how you could open the terminal
so I just used one shortcut Control Plus
backck to open the terminal you can also
go here and create one
terminal okay now I'll paste the line to
install tellin CSS in my system system
so let's wait a couple of minutes as you
can see it's installed in our system all
the packages and modules are install now
it will tell us to init this project so
let's do
that
okay it has successfully created the
configure file now inside the content
we'll copy paste this one as it is
saying to add these line configure your
template path add the path to all your
template file in the file okay so let's
just copy this
thing and paste in the
content now let's save
it okay so now next step is add the
tailin directives to your
CSS
now what will we do here is
let's go back to us Studio code and
create a
folder inside
this
that
SRC okay and inside this SRC we'll
create the file input.
CSS here we'll paste the code okay we
haven't copy that code all yet so let
copy
let's paste it here it's done
okay so I don't think so again that this
can replace the developers because this
is not the correct way to tell although
it has given us all the steps but any
developer can do the task in a very
short period of time it can just help
any developer but not take the job job
of the developer okay so let's move
ahead
and step would
be to go back next step to build the
process let's copy this one and start
the Tailwind CLI build process
okay let's copy and paste it here
right as you can see it's done in 273
milliseconds the output. CSS is
generated in this this file folder
right now we just have to use this file
output. CSS
okay let's see
now let's create
a file
here and name name it as
index.
HTML okay and inside that I'll write my
Boiler code just pressing shift and one
for the T comination mark and then the
Boiler code is done so we can change the
name of this and let's write here
as
side using char
okay
now one main thing that I wanted to tell
you that I have installed one uh
extension in my system which is the live
server this extension you can download
and this is very helpful
okay
let's open this
one now what we'll do is we'll link the
output. CSS file in our html. CSS so for
that I'll write here
link okay and inside this ring
I or you can just write link and then
click and then write
real Styles sheet
okay
cut what you'll do is we'll give the
path of the output. CH for that we WR
dot dot
slash list SL output. CSS it's just
showing
out
okay close this link tag and let's save
it and let's just right click and here
you'll see open with live server then
you will install the extension live
server so let's open this
one so this is working completely fine
it's showing us the title website using
jgp okay for
something I'll write here
welcome to Simply learn and then let's
save it and you'll see it's showing
welcome to Simply
okay now the next step would be to
create now let's open our
charb
and here we'll
write create
a
responsive
header
using let's first copy this
one
and
then
that's
okay so let's see whether it can give us
a right answer this time it
can let's
see okay it's giving us the code now for
the
[Music]
hter
okay
so it is showing us in the above code we
use tailin CSS classes to style the
header we set the background color to
Gray This one is the property of gray
color and then the text color would be a
white color in that n bar inside the
header we have a n element with the flex
and justify between okay classes to
horizontal Center the element space them
out evenly okay fine we also use PX4 and
py3 to add pedding to the navigation bar
cool for the mobile menu we use the
button with the MD hidden class to hide
it
on okay let's see the code now okay now
let's copy this HTML file let it write
everything so here we don't need this
one so let's delete this and let's here
right
header and let's comment it
down this okay let's past the code and
check whether
it's let's save it and let's go back to
our file so this is what chat gbt
created for us it's looking very good
actually
so let's inspect
it and let's see is it responsive or not
so this is completely responsive
guys okay very good
yeah
so this is really very good okay on
Surface do s 20 Ultra this is what show
on the mobiles okay now we'll go back to
the chat GPT and let's close this one
and stop generating and let's here right
create
a section
using
T CSS now let's see something went
wrong
okay let's see let's first copy this one
and refres
this and let's see how it will create
the hero section using tail
cases so it has created this nbar really
very good I didn't expect this from JT
but it's really very looking very good
it's simple and you can add these to
another Pages just using the anchor tag
there we can just give the path so I'll
show you www.
[Music]
simply. so this one is
okay so whenever I click on this one it
will redirect us to the simpon but uh
the URL is wrong we can just go back to
Simply
learn.com and let's copy
the and let's go back to
code and let's here write the URL okay
save it and let's
see yeah this is how this works let's
close this one okay now let's see what
is the
code okay let's copy this code and let's
see how this is working so it is also
giving us the complete code uh how it's
working how this step is working and all
as you can see it's giving us the max W
width 7 into one utility sets as Max
width for the container add to 7 XL
which is 12 112 RM or 7 92 pixels it's
giving us all the explanation for the
code it has written for us so let's
check it and after the header I'll paste
that code and let's save it and
see okay this is really very good
guys yeah I didn't expect this from
chart gbt but it's looking very good
so um till if I am a developer so if I
had to write this much of codee it'll
take me around 2 three hours at least
but with the help of chat gbt it only
created in 5 10 minutes so this is very
good actually now let's open the chart
GPT again and here we'll create
a information
section okay
let's
information
section
using
tail let's see
now till now it's working really very
good now it is writing a code for us so
as you can
see again very
good
now let's copy this one and paste it
under
this save it and let's check so this is
the information section this has created
for
us
right important information location
office Arts contactors and all right you
can also regenerate it for something
else okay now we it will create
something else for
us
right if you don't like something we can
just regenerate and create another one
so let just let's copy this one
now it's telling us everything about the
code and here after that I'll write this
and save it let's check what's this okay
this is the information section it has
created for us that this is something CH
data and if you don't like this one also
you can again regenerate the response
this is really an amazing feature of CH
gbt okay so now it's creating the the
third option we can countlessly ask him
to uh create again and again for us the
response let's copy this one okay and
let's remove all of it
because it's looking very
clumsy now let's see okay this
information section is information
section Welcome to our website this is
what it's written
okay now let's ask him to create
something else
okay let's copy this text create
informative and paste it using Tailwind
with one image I'll check whether it can
response to my things if I want to
create one image on the left or right
side and then the text on the other side
let's see whether it can create it for
us or not okay create informative
section using CH G with one image on the
right side and the text on
the left
side now let's
see whether it can create that or not
for us right just an simple command so
we'll check whether it can create or add
the
image okay you classes but text
but okay the image class
also and it's taking the source from an
API called called unsplash I have
covered this unsplash API on my previous
videos okay okay now let's copy this and
paste it on our code let's delete this
one and paste this one on the
website okay so the image is quite large
we can reduce the sizes but in the
starting only I have told you I'll not
add anything in the code so I'm not do
anything in the code right so we can
change the size it's really good as I
have told him to add the image on the
right side and the text on the left side
that's doing the same for the user so
this is really very helpful for the
developer but as I have already told you
it will cannot replace the developers
because uh I'm the developer I only
knows how to uh do things as I have
showed you that it has given me so many
wrong answers before before that before
this one this has given me three answers
but it was not up to the mark so I had
to told him that to uh create uh like
this image on the right and I've
explained it to uh chart GPT then it
created this one for us okay and
whenever I'll refresh this page the
image will get changed this is the
unlash API how this works okay we can
change the
images
also this is random just write
here coding okay now you will see the
images that will come here
okay let's
see let's check it
that's not taking any other
name yeah I don't know why it's not
working but let's not waste time on this
random is also
fine till now it's looking really very
good
okay now the next step would be to add
the service section okay so let's CH GP
to create service section for us
okay
using now let's
see who's
coming
okay
class for the of the
bo really very
good so look how beautifully it has been
created
right yeah
okay let's see
it's done now let's copy the code and go
to our
editor and
here we'll write this code and let's
spacee
it let's
check okay so it's not aligned straight
but we can align it so it's showing us
that the services that this website is
providing what we offer and this is some
junk data web design web marketing and
all so let's check whether it
is
yeah okay so what this one is doing here
is it's using
only three classes it is
using and the center
Center these all are using the same
class but let's find out why the
image is
coming like
that
right you can align
it you guys want me to align this we can
align this right
okay
so let's just align one it's just one
line okay we can align that so let's dig
deep into this
code
okay this image
classes okay
image the same justify Center and then
it's using the flex shrink
function let rounded
large okay
with the wi
56 let's make it 50 and
[Music]
check and let's go back to the
code the size of this
first okay let's SC go back to the Chart
again again regenerate the new response
and let's see how the second response is
looking right let's wait a couple of
seconds
more
okay let's see the response that it is
creating we need a minimalist design
okay I was just observing the code
and see how it's
looking we can also change the color of
the customiz it uh this website on our
own but it's really very good I'm really
impressed with this this really will
help developers creating
websites
okay let's go back
to still
creating after that we will create the
about section for the page okay
okay okay it's again giving us that
design and all
part
great if I'll tell CH gbt to create uh
this service section and this is my
requirement and all it will definitely
create that I guess now I'm impressed
really impressed with the code clean
code it's
writing and it's also responsive I
haven't told it to create the responsive
uh code but it's really very good it's
responsive I I show
you inspect I was just seeing that only
whether it is responsive or not if
you'll see okay let me just cut this
part let's
just
yeah so this is how we'll check the
responsive take and
let's see that these three uh home about
contacts are
vanished and this is the header part
that we created and then the up one is
the Nar this is the information
section and services section is also
there this this is all
responsive
okay so we'll check how it's looking on
Samsung
xs20 this is how it's
looking really good yeah let's move on
to the code copy this code and coming
back to the code Eder let's delete this
section
okay now let's paste it and
see
okay it's giving us an
error this is what it created for us
it's I guess uh little
less
or it was already writing the code and I
stopped it's fine it's not a mistake
let's stop and regenerate the
response let's copy this
again coming back to
the
Chart not
working refresh chart GP
again service section let's see it's
really fast
now
okay let's observe this one
first our services what we offer web
design there must some lines about
digital marketing and I'm thinking there
is also
one part which I cut
down
not mistake it was mine because I stop
generating the
response
okay really good let's copy this TT now
and paste it
under and let's delete this and paste
it let's check it this
time so
this is how this one is looking now this
is also really looking very good we can
decrease the size of this image do not
worry about that uh this is the service
our services and some junk data here we
can write this uh website is providing
this and that okay service one that we
provide this service we provide this
service and we provide this service okay
this is all about
that right really very good really very
good it's really very good okay we can
change everything from it customize it
on our our needs
thing let's just go back okay this one
is looking good okay now let's ask Char
GPD to create the about page for us so
we'll write
create
so I think uh meanwhile it's writing the
code for us I wanted to tell you that
chat is great for uh for everyone but as
I know the code how this code is working
I know what is section what is Dev class
and what are the function this grid
system that's using maxw uh it's using
the Excel function I know everything
about it uh and if you are a fresher or
you don't know about anything about the
coding uh I think you should first uh
know about the language or the framework
then only ask uh this to chat gbt or
take help from the chat right uh if you
don't know about the language or the
framework and you'll just tell CH to
create this and this for us it's easy it
will create for you but uh it will not
uh help you in your future so according
to me
just uh use it to learn not to work
okay
so let's move
ahead and the path is given
okay it was again managed let ask it
again
responsive
about
section
using
T okay I just m but it is very
intelligent
I misspelled the Tailwind spelling and
then it corrected it very
good so this is not the complete code
for the about page uh I last it
to
let's see whether it will take this
command or
not right great so let's
see after this about section we'll
create this contact page and then
we'll create final this website
right so this is really very helpful for
the developers I must say
so let's copy this
and code and paste it under this
section
okay so this is how the about page is
looking really very good the image size
is 500 into 500 it's really very B so we
can change the size of the
image let's
see is
that right
250 and the image will not come
again
let's just delete this
Source copy the
unlash Epi for the random
image
right that command is really really
useful okay I forgot to add that yeah
this yeah this is how this about is
looking really very good guys really
very good if I tell Char to create this
on the right side or this image I want
on the left hand side or right hand side
it will definitely do for us as I have
given him the uh task in this section
information section it definitely worked
so I must say it's really very good so
now let's move on to to
the contact page
okay let's here write
create create a
responsive
contact
Section
[Music]
using
D and I I'll ask him to do add some
sections for us so let's see whether it
can take up that or
not okay let's give it in a second shot
let's first see how is the contact
Section is looking then we'll tell him
to improvise
that so it's just taking a section class
inside that section class it's using
some classes which is flex T and all and
it's giving
us it's really
good let's copy this text again and
paste it
here so the contact D is also looking
very good get in touch
and then it will redirect us to
the that really good really the images
sizes are uh large but we can reduce it
it's not a big deal but it's all looking
very good right so one thing is left is
the footer part let's ask it to create a
footer for us now this is the last and
final step for
this
create
the
section
using this is really very good looking
very good let's add
the splash
and
then do it
here
okay so this is how it's looking now so
overall if I see it really given us a
good good output really so uh I will say
CH gbt can only help uh us that's it as
this code that is created by chat GPT
for us we can't use it directly this
structure that chat GPT created for us
is good but we need to add so many
things before deploying it right uh if
I'll see this one we need to add this uh
uh services in the center and we need to
uh uh arrange the text and the services
we need to change the size of the
services if uh the client wants it uh uh
horizontally then we have to change that
we need to change this image size as in
front of you I change this email sizes I
use the different apis so overall it's
very good but there uh is so many things
uh that we have to do okay and for that
developers are needed as technology
advances in all aspects of Our Lives
programming has become increasingly
important it is used in many fields and
industries including software
development gaming and entertainment
education scientific research web
development and many more so needless to
say the demand for programming and
coding in the IT industry will probably
keep increasing for the foreseeable
future but where does chatut open AI
popular language model fall in this
chain that's exactly what we are
focusing on in this today's video on
that note welcome to the simply learn
YouTube channel today we are here with
an interesting video on chat gut for
programming chat gut is after all a
product of artificial intelligence if
you want to know more about artificial
intelligence and become an expert in the
field of AI consider the artificial
intelligence engineer master program by
simply learn and master those necessary
skills check out the link in the
description for more details as I said
earlier programming is utilized in many
domains like web development robotics
mobile development machine learning and
so on so how can a program achieve
maximum code efficiency nowadays we have
eii based tools like charity to make our
programming experience more efficient
although they are several coding
resources platforms such as stack
Overflow and GitHub where programmers
can find solutions to their technical
programming questions charab stands out
from the competition because of its
quick response time usability and
support for numerous languages among
many other benefits now let's first
discuss how chip Works chip generates
responses to the text input using a
method called Transformer architecture a
large volume of text is fed into the
chat GPT from various sources including
books websites and other social media
platforms the model then uses this
information to forecast the following
word in a phrase based on the words that
came before it the charb systems allows
users to enter text or queries and then
the system uses its training data and
algorithms to produce the right answer
the answer is created after the input
text has been examined and the pattern
most likely to match the input have been
identified using the training data in
short charity is designed to respond to
queries logically and command more
quickly and accurately but why do
programmers use chip on a regular basis
chip assists programmers by offering
programming related answers and
solutions and helping them improve their
skills beside that charity is utilized
for code generation code completion code
review and a natural language interface
let us understand each in detail charity
is trained to generate the code or even
the entire program described in the
natural language specified by what they
want a program to do and then Char could
generate the relevant code look at the
example of how CH GPT generates the code
so now open the CH GPT and you can type
any program that you want CHP to
generate so I will give write a palum
program in Java so here you can type
write
a
palum program in
Java so using Java programming language
it should generate the whole
program so as you can see it has
generated the program so it has used a
class name called pandrum Checker and it
has used e pandrum as a method name and
also it will give the explanation on the
program so you can see here why it is
explaining why e pandrum is used as a
method and U it also explains the for
for Loop if a condition and so on next
we have code completion charge is
trained to generate Snippets of code or
even fully fledged programs it can
generate a list of possible code
completion depending on the context of
the users incomplete piece of Code by
automatically producing the entire code
it can help the developers save time and
minimize errors next let's see the
example of code completion using chip so
even if the program is explained in
natural language chip will generate the
proper code and give the complete code
so let's type
here using a
function write a
program to
convert the
string in
uppercase so using which language let's
keep using C
programming and enter it once again
so as you can see we have just said that
using a function write a program to
convert the string in upper case so
using C programming language and using C
programming language it has used
function and you know this is the
function convert to uppercase and has
given the complete code for string or to
convert a string in uppercase and also
it gave the explanation here the convert
to uppercase function takes a pointer to
a string as its argument and then
iterates over each character in the
string using a for Loop so it explained
why for Loop is used why two upper is
used and why the method convert to
uppercase is used
everything so let's say uh we'll give
one piece of code like
void to
Upper car s
strr
so as you can see we just gave the
method to Upper and it's generating the
complete code so this is how charity
works for code completion next code
review jity can analyze code identify
the bugs or errors in the program and
further help resolve them it allows
developers to fix errors more quickly so
now let's have a look at the example of
code review so in in this example Char
will review the code so even if the code
has some mistake it will give the proper
output let's say we have given the
example here so we give the function or
a method called
upper and here we are giving the keyword
called upper so it should check whether
this piece of code is proper or is there
any mistake in
this so as I said uh it's saying that
the given code appears to have logical
error as the function upper is being
called recursively on itself inside the
loop so instead of giving two upper we
just give upper here right so using the
keyword two upper only then the string
can be converted to uppercase so here we
gave just upper so it says that it is
having this piece of code is having a
logical error and it gives a proper code
for
us so I hope it's clear and then we have
natural language interface with the use
of chat GPT a software application can
be given a natural language user
interface that enables users to
communicate with it through natural
language instructions rather than
through conventional user interfaces
next let's see how charity helps the
programmers for natural language
interface so let's say we'll give
here
create a software
application
where the
user asked to
enter
credential for the too
app
enter so as you can see the charge will
give the steps so it can provide you
with an outlet for creating software
applications that requires the user to
enter credential for a to-do app so here
it is few steps that we need to follow
to do a to-do
app so it's giving the explanation step
by
step
so it says that determine the
programming language and framework then
set up the database to store the user
information and then create the
registration page and then finally
create the login page as well and once
the user is successfully logged in um
you know it will have the options like
add edit and delete task as well and
then finally implement the security
measures to you know protect your
passwords and then test the application
to ensure that it works as intendent and
the user data is being stored and
retrieved correctly so it gives the
steps of how it has to be developed
enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment and post-graduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box I'm sure you all
are aware of Charity at this point the
Revolutionary new AI based chatbot
developed by open AI has taken the World
by storm thanks to its near lifelike
responses and a very intricate pattern
of answers we have never seen this level
of expertise from a chatbot before which
really made us think to what extent can
we push it there are many questions on
lead code that even the most experienced
programmers have difficulty answering so
we wanted to see how far chat gbd can
take us have we finally reached the
stage where AI is going to replace us
let's find out so basically here we will
be listing 10 really difficult questions
that we found on lead code popularly
asked while hiring and other Superior
examinations and see if chat GPD can
actually answer or solve those difficult
questions or not but before you like to
watch more such interesting videos then
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's get
started so here is the lead code let's
see uh in our list which is the first
first question that we are going to
implement in our chart gbd and see if
it's able to solve it or not mainly
we'll focus on hard category questions
only
so according to my research there's a
question of
median of two sorted
arrays so as you can see the success
rate is 35 .7% so let's see if the chart
GPD is able to do this question so first
let us go through the
question
okay press enter let's see what it first
returns
uh on a one approach to solving this
problem is to use a modified binary
search algorithm to find the median of
the two sorted areas so right now it's
particularly giving the logic which we
can actually imply to solve this
question and uh this is a good about the
chart gpds that before uh giving the
code it's actually explaining how they
are putting the logic in together in the
code so probably you can use this logic
to create your own program but let's see
how sensible this code
is quite a ly
program this in Python so if uh you are
looking for your Solutions on chat GPD
you can always opt out or you know
mention the specific program you want
the code in so okay it's it's also gives
that okay that the time complexity will
be b o log Min m or n so let's see if
it the case or
not so we have copied it and we'll
quickly paste it over
here as you can
see uh as we know that python is uh very
sensitive towards its uh syntax and and
you can see the indentation over here is
perfect but here it's not so I feel that
something like this is something with
lead code so let me just quickly Rectify
this you can see I have cleared out the
indentation issue and let's just quickly
run this program so that we can get an
idea if this is the correct
program uh now you can see here we have
an error let's see copy this and see
what CH GPD has to say for
this
so if you remember when we actually saw
this question there were three arguments
passed through this function which was
self nums one and nums 2 ask GPT if it
can write the code with self argument
and see if it's
correct
wait that if it can pass a self argument
through that function and see if it can
generate a new
code okay now it has cleared that yes it
takes three
arguments
let's this
code it over here again I think we will
have to go through the indentation
process oh no this time it's fine okay
so now quickly run this program let's
see if this time it passes all the test
cases or
not
okay I think it doesn't need because the
class is already mentioned over
here uh
yeah okay the run time is 35 Ms and as
we can see case one and case two is
definitely passed
so let us see
if this board can pass all the test
cases internally mentioned in this
question now you can see the first three
cases are actually accepted but the
other three are not there's a runtime
error
so the first question in our list Jad
GPT was unable to solve so let's move on
to our next
question that is zigzag
conversion now let me quickly search for
it this is the question here also you
can see the success rate is definitely
below 50 and uh the difficulty level is
medium so the hard one charge was not
able to solve let's see if this can be
done
so it will give a string that will be
written in a zigzag pattern on a given
number of rows and uh then you have to
read the line in a certain as you can
see over
here we have to write the code that will
take a string and make this conversion
given in a number of
R this also means a certain amount of
certific uh repeat do also given a
certain specifications that we exactly
want so this time we'll make sure that
we are mentioning
everything so let's quickly copy
this
yeah
okay now that we have mentioned all the
specifications uh let me
quickly
feed feed and P Ed now let's see what
code it has to
generate it's implementing the code in
C++ so meanwhile it's generating the
code let's
quickly like the code oh it's already
C++
okay
okay it's also suggesting that we can
definitely use Python and
Java and it's generating an alternative
code as well for
us that's
sharp just quickly copy this
[Music]
code a one I think it's a okay so it's
generating in uh
Java it's generating we'll definitely
have a look at its alternative codes as
well let's quickly have a look at what
it has to C++ one the first code
generated by it uh is correct or
not okay copy the
code pasted over
here dilation
error okay
okay 28
okay so
let's this
error the one thing definitely this time
we have mentioned all the constraints
criteria specifications that we wanted
in a code but again
charging questions we have implemented
till
now let's see if it has any success rate
in further
okay it seems
okay now it is okay so this time it is
uh generating the
solution considering the error in
Java let uh see what it has to say say
in Java and we'll make it specific that
the error was in C++ program so
generates the correct
code Plus+
program
what it has to
say well
it's see so this error is something
related to the compiler and now it is
giving the updated code in
C++ is the correct one or
not she apologizing for making errors in
their
Solutions it
fascinating
uh
yeah
paste the code over here I don't see
there's a lot of difference or changes
over here let's see if it runs or
not let me see if all the braces are
covered over here or
not
I think it's missing a
brace
okay so there was a syntax error one
brace was
missing um I don't
know B that definitely something with
the code but okay we can give that to
chat gbt it was partially lead codes
issue because we were copying still it
was not giving the error that there is a
brace
missing has passed the first three cases
mentioned over here and the run time is
3 Ms now just let us submit this code
and see if it passes all the rest of the
cases or not
minded this time we have actually
mentioned all the constraints so let's
see if this has
into okay so this time it has passed all
the test cases but still my conclusion
with this question is uh it was still
not able to generate the solution in one
go uh but still I can give that to
charge GPT because the first eror that
we faced was more of a lead CES issue
because it was something with
compile and CH GPT was able to give a
proper oh now let's go back to our
problems
list so right now the score is one in
one it was unable to solve one question
and one not so let's have a look at the
third question and see if that brings
any difference to the chart gpt's
scoreboard right now or
not third question that we are going to
deal with is
substring
with concatenation of all
words this is in the category again and
the success success rate is
31.1% which is even lesser than the
first question that we faced which was
is Medan of the two sorted
Aras we trying here we are actually
trying to cover all the Spectra the huge
Spectra of different types of uh
questions and you know categories
available in coding and uh to give you
an idea of
how beneficial charity can be for you to
solve difficult questions which can be
helpful for your interview base in
companies or you you can say well
established companies or mang companies
so here this video is specifically for
you to give an idea that whether you can
use it for your benefit and you know to
get an idea or you can actually uh
compare it with
yours uh and you can get a you know
wider range of different types of
approaches to a certain question
so let's start with the third
question that you're given a string and
an array of strings probably words and
all the strings of words are of the same
length now a concatenated substring in s
is a substring that contains all the
strings of any permutation of words
concatenated
here you can see it's given an example
that if words has AB b c d EF then AB CD
EF basically it uh has done all the
permutation and combinations that can be
done using that specific
array
uh and condition that AC CD BF is not a
concatenated substring because it is not
the concatenation of any permutation of
words so we have to basically return the
starting indices of all the concatenated
substring in the S
string also you can choose any order for
it here it has also given uh two
examples for you
to understand the question in a better
perspective
now uh copy this question and see
if what programming language a chooses
to answer this
time
start with new chart
again copy these
constraints
okay it's just a
question okay this is the solution that
we are getting right now you requested a
model that is not compatible with this
engine please contact us through our
help center at
help. open.com for further questions let
me just quickly refresh it if it has
something to do with the you know demand
also sometimes it happens that the
console is very busy and you're unable
to
implement uh your task in it so again
let's
quickly paste it over
here we want a code write a code
return
now press
enter time definitely it's not giving
the same error let's see this time it
charer P has anything to give as a
solution okay so it's generating the
code in
Python more thing every time charge
doesn't follows a similar pattern as you
can see in the first question it
explained the logic first and uh then
implemented the code second time it just
gave you the approach not the logic and
then implemented the code in multiple
languages uh first choosing for
C++ and this time it straight went for
the code so definitely we can say that
it has some different styles of
generating their code and explaining the
code I think it depends on the
understanding how they want the code to
be presented in front of the user and to
give the perspective that if the code is
understandable or not and if the code
has multiple approaches I think Char is
capable to capable enough to give
that that the code is generated let's
quickly copy
it
and paste it over
here I feel the indentation issue is
going to be
there it was not
there okay
F probably I think if we back
space let me quickly Rectify this and
[Applause]
I'll you once the indentations
are
e
see the indentation is uh corrected now
uh let's have a look at the code if it's
correct or not let's quickly run
it definitely it has given our first
syntax error again I can see that even
specific video question it definitely
goes to at least one error which is
mainly the syntax
one
sure if that is something with the lead
code or you know with
the chart GPD code
generation
okay now that we have given the error
okay it seems that the error is caused
by the use of type hints the function
type were introduced and the version we
are using is lower than that okay so
basically it's generating now in the
python version uh probably this code
is well suited for different version of
python let's change it then and see if
that
helps
it on is actually generating the
code okay again given the other I think
it's again something with the
self
uh one the new code generated is
here we definitely come back to that
error and have a look at the Python 3
code
also uh first let's copy this code
and
e
and giving the same
[Music]
error here and see what it has to
say uh you know every time the charity
generates the python code we
cannot ever take self as an argument but
the
lead as you can see when we start the
code it's already mentioned what
arguments we need to pass from that
particular function so I think that is
something with the lead code
so that what all arguments it's passing
even though we have mentioned everything
this time we have mentioned all the
constraints we have mentioned all the uh
necessary specifications that we want in
the code even then the code is not
correct in the one go so probably I'll
get this point to GPD it's something
with the lead code because it's passing
that parameter and everything we have to
mention that parameter pretty much when
we do the Char is able to solve the
question so let's see what let me U
actually mention that
pass uh self parameter self argument
from that parameters one of make it a
one of the
parameters
processing
that yes self can be passed as the first
argument to the given function now let's
see if that it's able to give the
correct solution or not again we can see
it's uh generating the code in you
know Pon 3 but we can give that to CH
GPD that either it uses python or Python
3 the error is with the self argument so
once we mention that error and when we
mentioned that specification that if CH
GP can pass self argument through that
particular function in that code the
solution is pretty
much right so here it's also
implementing and giving the
answer okay it also has mentioned that
uh it's important to mention import
imported list and counter so
okay just copy this because again there
will be a lot of uh ination
issues okay now that we have
it let's copy the
code already mentioned so yeah we'll
just
copy it from the
[Music]
function paste
it let run this code and see if it has
the solution in it or
not yeah there's an indentation
issue let
me
again as you can see it is able to pass
all the test cases here and the run time
is 28
Ms now let us submit this question and
see if it is able to pass other test
cases or
not accepted so it is able to pass all
the test cases and uh I think this is
something with lead code again uh
whenever we are generating the python
code we are actually passing self
argument uh in lead code but chart GPD
is not assuming it so this solution is
definitely correct uh even though we are
specifying everything we will have to be
more specific that we have to run one
more argument uh from the function so
that it you know generates the solution
in one go so let us uh try that in our
next
question but we can definitely see chart
gbd was able to solve this so now the
scoreboard is 2 and one uh among the
three questions it is definitely able to
solve two questions even in the first
question it was able to generate a
correct solution but it was not that
accurate to pass all the test
cases
to our question
list the next that we are going to cover
is in
Queens category but still the success
rate is 63% over here again a new genre
or question we are covering over here
let us see if
solve it or not definitely the success
rate shows that many people were able to
do it definitely more than half of
people who have attempted it so let's
see if the question can this AI can beat
that or
not so uh I have copied this question
the question mentions that the end
Queen's puzzle is the problem of placing
end Queen Queens on an n in to end
chessboard such that no two queens
attack each other given an integer n
return all distinct solutions to the n
Queen puzzle so basically n is any given
number and you have to create a puzzle
of n n and you have to arrange all the
Queens in such uh you know way also the
number of Queens in the board will be
equal to the
number and in such a way that it is not
able B to attack each other in any
case po it this part of the
question and the constraint is just
one let
me that it will be easier to keep a
track of uh what all questions Char gbt
is able to
solve
so these questions are very popular uh
in
interviews uh whenever you actually go
to technical rounds and uh for
prestigious companies these questions
are very popular uh they are considered
as very uh suitable questions to check
uh to check your you know IQ and to
check your potential that how well aware
you are towards your coding
potential that we have pressed enter it
is giving the logic it is going to
implement in its code one approach to
solve the end Queen's puzzle is to use
backtracking idea is to start by placing
a queen in the First Column of the first
row so let's see if the Cod is again
keep capable to you know solve it or not
again it's giving the python
code generating the code let us quickly
see whether it's python or Python
3 Python
okay once the code is generated I'll
also write that you need to pass one
more argument from the main
function uh that is self and uh let let
it generate a the code again and see
that code can run in one go or
not
what I want and let see sure here's an
example of how you can pass an
additional parameter self let's see if
if it
suits the code or
not
the solve and queen function is a method
of the N Queen's class and it takes self
as its first parameter followed by the
integer n so yes this solution does take
self as a parameter so let's see if this
can run in one go or not because this
time we have already covered the most uh
frequently generated error which is synx
error ER of not mentioning parameter
self let me see the indentation if it's
correct or
not this time uh let us quickly on
this
plus okay there you go now you can see
that it has actually run the code in one
go and all the test cases are passed in
one go even the run time is 39 MS
so definitely chat gbt is able to
provide the solutions the Logics in a
proper manner it's just that we have to
be more specific with what we want
exactly uh from chat gbt right now we
can see that it has been able to
successfully
generate of five uh questions that we
have actually implemented till now out
of which four are from hard
category let us submit this code and see
if it also covers all the test cases
inter internally fed in for this
question just a second I think I will
have to submit it
again there you go it has accepted all
the test cases and this question is done
by chart GPT it has actually
implemented question that we are going
to cover till now I can say Char GB has
taken the lead it is pretty much able to
implement all the questions uh I think
there are still some range of questions
that it is not able to implement as we
saw the first one was not a huge
success but uh I can still give that to
charity as it is in Ai and still in a
you know developing mode but still if it
can give you 90% of the output correct
it is a pretty decent and you know
amazing thing to
do question is shortest subarray with
some at least K now let me search for
it
again this question is from heart
category and its success rate is even
low which is 26.1 let's see this
question can be solved by chart
G let's have a look at the question
given an integer AR nums and an integer
K return the length of the shortest
non-empty sub array of nums with a some
of at least K so if there is no such
subar return minus
one
soar is a contagious part of an array it
has also given a description of what an
array is or what sub array is so now
that we
have a new
chat and let
me
means so here is one way to solve the
problem initialize two pointers uh left
and right both pointing to the first
element of the array initialize a
variable so now this time this it is
giving pointers to solve this question
uh you know a perfect approach in a
sequential manner so that you can also
use these pointers and the Logics it's
giving to actually Implement your own
code apart from you know asking it to
generate a
code I can see that it has given the
pointers but not the code
specific
oh yes uh it's giving an implementation
of the algorithm in
Python uh again we can see it's not the
Python 3 it's python uh little low
version of python
um switch
to
Python and we have to pass self
so it has generated the code and
explained what all variables and what
all statements have the individual fun
functionality as so we have also asked
it to pass self parameter through its
function and then write the code so
let's see if it adares to it and
generates a new code with self
parameter okay so
here is the new code with self pass to
the main
function
now I do have confidence on chat GPT
till now that it was able to generate
logical and you know pretty decent
solutions for every
question is pass to the class as an
argument when an object is created and
is stored as an instance variable the
shortest subar takes K as an argument
which is the Target some so basically
it's trying to explain the code that
what exactly it's doing and what
individual statements have as an
influence on the
code and whatever parameters they are
passing what influence or what position
they hold in the
code uh definitely charge abity is not
just generating the code uh you know
it's also explaining the logic and
approaches to
it and when it's generating the code as
you can see here they have legit
explained the whole code how it's
actually functioning that's a good way
to you know
put emphasis on you know put a
confidence on the
solution remove this
yeah typ error okay let
me
okay so it's apologizing it made a
mistake in its previous response the
init method should take two arguments
one for the nums array and one for key
so now it's again generating a new code
or ading to the syntax error or type
error generated
let right or
not
mentioned that here the El meod takes
two arguments one for the nums array and
one for the K which was the error
exactly and it's again explaining the
whole code so that one person who
watches code or you know the logic could
understand the functionality of
it
let's see if this code can
run Bo checking for indentation removing
class and
run is one more type error
let's copy it
and we mention that we want self
argument to be
passed it is still not able to generate
you know the correct solution twice so
let's see if this time it can work
out
issue though with the
code apologize for the confusion seems
that I misunderstood
the that you are trying to call the
function directly without creating an
instance of the class in that function
outside of the class and simply Call It
by passing the parameters like this is
okay the code is definitely generated by
itself definitely I am not calling any
function uh the code I coped was
actually generated by CH GPD itself so
it's it contradicting its own pointers
maybe that we have copied the question
uh sorry the code let's paste
it again look for
indentation
and run this
code okay once again it is not able to
you know
pass I error is there and now again we
have to copy this error and paste
it again according to chat GB it was
confused with the context of the
question
uh like I said the code was anywh
generated by Char gup so yeah this time
I think CH GPT is trying to contradict
its own
Logics let's see if the current code can
do the miracle of solving this
question
[Music]
CL and
run okay so after four attempts of
running the codes generated by CH gpon
Le code but this particular question
finally now it's able to pass all the
test cases so I can I have a very
contradicting point right now uh not
exactly contradicting more of a skeptism
that okay chat gity does generates uh
proper code or logic but it doesn't
considers all the criterias or it also
has has a tendency of taking the
question in a wrong
context so I feel that when we as a
human try to solve these questions we
definitely try to implement all the
Logics and if we get it we can actually
get the code in one
go or you know demand of the question
and being AI being the superior version
or you know trying to be the superior
version of human brain and going to the
extents of a human
brain still faces those issues can be a
you know drawback for chat GPT because
you can see for this specific question
we have faced multiple types of error
and we have seen chity contradicting its
own prior code
so definitely this is something to
consider or you know something to think
about
submit this
code and after like I said after giving
four attempts it is still not able to
pass all the test cases it is only able
to pass 61 out of 97 test
cases which is almost 70% of the test
cases 30% of the test cases are still
not passed even though we mentioned all
the constraints we have mentioned the
comments we have mentioned all the
errors that this particular code can go
through still it was not able to
generate the proper code that could go
through all the test cases so this was a
fail for charge uh at least till now we
have made out this point that Char GPT
is definitely not able to solve every
question
question array with same
average for
it
let aray with
this is from the category of hard
questions and the success rate is only
25% uh Let me refresh it and remove this
code now let's have a look at the code
what it demands so you are given an
integer are nums now you should move
each element of nums into one of the two
arrays A and B such and B are are non
empty and the average of array a is
equal to average of array B now return
true if it is possible to achieve
that condition is not
justified so given a note that for an
array uh average array is the sum of all
the elements of array over the length of
ARR okay so it it is giving the logic of
how to actually you know find out the
average of what average is exactly and
also it has given a few examples to give
you IDE how the code needs to be
projected or
implemented past copy the code and paste
it
okay it is possible to achieve this by
checking all the possible subsets of the
nums array and comparing the averages of
the subsets so definitely it has given
you the approach uh the way you can
actually think of solving this question
uh however this approach would have a
Time complexity so it's also giving that
this approach can have a Time complexity
of O to the power
uh in so again it's suggesting a
different approach a more efficient
approach that will be using dynamic
programming now that can be used to find
the subsets with a specific average and
create a 2d array with the length of I
and J will that will be the length of
the two we have actually given as input
and represents whether or not it is
possible to get a sum of J using the
first elements of the nams are
[Music]
so so the time complexity of this
approach would be o n s so definitely is
not given a code uh let me ask for
it uh
not for every question chat GB is
generating a code it is also mentioning
just and the approaches that we can
actually use uh definitely again we will
have to mention that what we want from
them as you can see I've mentioned this
time to write a code for it and now it's
generating a new code for it
is also mentioning comments that what
every snippet of the code is actually
for and what it will do like here you
can see it will fill the 2dr DP uh DP
stands for dynamic programming this here
it has mentioned initialize the First
Column as true so it is also mentioning
the comments for better idea of you know
understanding the code in a better
way also giving the note that this
implementation assumes that the nums
array is non empty and that the elements
of the nums array are non- negative inte
fgures okay also the above
implementation will return the possible
subset that can be formed by the array
to fulfill the given condition and not
puling true and false but that's what we
want exactly right uh still okay let us
this approach is in Python so let's copy
this and see this code can run on or
not I can clearly see that again it
needs to pass
self uh
parameter
indentation
give it a heads
up
or I have mentioned what I want
specifically uh sure here is an example
of how you can pass the self parameter
so now the current solution will pass
self
okay there was an air
okay
and it has generated a new code uh
considering the criteria I just
mentioned that I need self parameter to
be passed through the function can
parip so I have copied it and let's
quickly paste it over
here uh you know pass all the cases are
not wait uh we need to remove
this okay it's done now quickly just run
this
program okay so here is
uh error attribute error solution object
has no attribute okay so let me copy it
and paste it over here and see what chat
GPT has to say about this
error okay the error message solution
object has has no
attribute uh split array same average
suggest that there is no method named
with this in the solution class so it is
likely that the test case is trying to
call this method but it does not exist
in your implementation anyway that I
have not mentioned this method this was
given by char g itself so again we can
see the condition that it is
contradicting its own so again it has
generated new response and it says that
it should resolve the issue and the test
case should be able to call this
particular method
correctly so that is something for us to
decide now let us copy this code and see
that now is it able to run or not and
pass all the test cases or
not and click on
run
okay now the new generated response does
works for this particular question and
the run time is 12 Ms and it th passes
the first two cases mentioned so let us
quickly submit this code and see if the
code is perfectly you know fine to deal
with all the test cases actually fed by
lead
code
okay now again we can see one more
situation that this code is not able to
pass all the test cases even though we
mentioned all the specifications
constraints and we were pretty precise
about the questions and parameters that
we want our code to be done in certain
form but still it is just able to pass
68 test cases out of 111 which is almost
50 to 60% of uh total amount of test
cases
so let's move on to the next
question that is find substring with
given hash value so let me quickly
search for this
question find
substring
with
value again it's it's a question from
hard category and the success rate is
22.2% so let's have a look at the
question what it demands so here the
hash of a zero indexed string of length
K given inte teers B and M is computed
using the following functions now hash
with parameters
SPM uh this this is the logic given how
we want our output to be demonstrated in
a certain value or how the hash can be
generated the particular formula uh how
you can get the hash value of your you
know uh
string so the question is you are given
a string and the
integers uh and you have to return the
first substring of that string of length
uh given to you here it's K the test cas
es will be generated such that an answer
always exists we are going to copy this
course and mention all the
specifications mentioned here in their
chart GPD console so that it gets all
the
specifications the code
and
so I have copied the code and paste it
over here now let's check for
indentation it's fine let's remove class
my
class
and again it faces a type error so let's
move on to the next question again we
saw that CH was not able to solve this
particular question coming back to our
list the next question in list that we
are going to cover is partition array
into two arrays to minimize some
difference let's quickly search for that
question partition array
to two
arrays again this question is from heart
category and the success rate is even
more low so let's have a look at the
question first it's partition array into
two arrays to minimize some difference
that is generated as the
output we can see that there are three
constraints so now quickly copy this
question and see if it is able to solve
this question or not first we have to
create a new
chat
copy all the
constraints
let's see what Chad jity has to say for
this particular
question let's ask it to generate a code
this time it has only generated a logic
not exactly Logic the approach that they
are going to follow or anyone can follow
to solve this
question
let me ask if it can generate a
code it's definitely taking longer time
to generate this code okay here is the
code which is possible python
implementation and
uh okay the code is generated and uh
it's mentioning that the code takes in
and input an array of integer called
nums so basically uh it's explaining
that what it actually it's doing which
is pretty much explained in the question
itself that what exactly it needs to
function like and what will be the
variables and what will be the inputs
and how it needs to be segregated to uh
obtain our Optimum
result
so let's copy
this and
paste it over here again like I said we
can see that it's generating you know
uh again we could see
that pass self
parameter
okay in
the
attribute error let's quickly copy
it paste it over
here see what CH GPD has to say about it
okay that you have seen that after
placing the error it's giving that error
message you're seeing suggest that
there's a problem with the function name
in your code so the error message is
indicating that there is no function
called minimum difference within the
solution
uh also I have seen that apart from the
function name it doesn't have a self
parameter so let me just write it
down
self
argument
in apps wait let me copy that will be
better
and write
a new code with
it let me see if it can generate a new
code this
time oh yeah it has a GRE sure it there
is an example and here's the
code so I have copied
this
and pasted
over
here see any such huge difference in the
syntax or the logic of the code but yeah
we can definitely think of running now
let's run this
code me copy it and paste it over here
again an error has prompted out I don't
know how uh
valid code we'll get after projecting
this error over here in chart
GPD so yeah definitely considering the
error message you are seeing is
indicated that the function is returning
INF which is not a valid value for the
expected return type
integer so so in the base case where I
and J are both zero the value of is set
to float which is positively Infinity
however the expected output is an
integer so this valid this value is not
valid so again considering this change
the Char is giving a new code so let us
see how valid this new code
is okay I can see that it has changed
logic over here instead of float INF it
has changed it has uh written a new
syntax and New Logic over there now and
also Char gu guarantees that this may
solve the issue of returning INF as the
value let's see how accurate chart GPT
here
is
now we have pasted
logic uh yeah
as oh sorry I need to remove these two
lines
okay now let's quickly run this
program okay so now as you can see it
could only pass one test case but not
the first two so there's no point of
submitting this code as we can see that
the logic for this code or this code as
a whole is
not well moving on next in the list we
have
is longest common saath now let's see
longest
common
subpath so this question also comes from
category of hard questions and the
success rate is 27% now let's see what
this question demands actually now let's
quickly copy this question with all the
constraints and whatever ever apart from
example is left on the screen we need to
copy it as you can see over here you
cannot just miss out on any
specifications talking about the
constraints
copy and paste now
enter giving the approach to solve this
question which is dynamic programming
approach okay we didn't got any code
over here so let's
try that if it can present a
code okay so I have asked to write a
code for this and uh yes CH GPT has
definitely agreed to provide me a code
for it uh Char is done with its
explanations I'll uh type it out and
wait for the new code which will contain
self as a parameter that it's this code
is pretty similar to the previous one
it's just that it's using the self
argument the function as it was
mentioned by me so let's quickly copy
this
code paste it over here
check for the
indentation run this
code I don't should be
any okay I spoke too fast here we have
another error let's see what charp has
to say about
this the list index out of range error
is likely occurring on line 10 because
the indices I and J are being properly
bounc checked before being used to
access elements in the path and DPR okay
so we have found a new code let's
quickly copy this code and see if this
code is capable of you
know eliminating the errors we probably
found
cck copy and
paste let me check for the
ination done and
run then we got a error over here even
though after providing so many
specifications and criterias and errors
and conditions yet chat GP is not able
to provide a perfect solution for the
code uh moving on to the last question
of our list that is going to be uh sum
of total strength of wizards hopefully
this question does some magic for chat
GPT and prove itself lucky for chat GPT
graph for this video because for now we
can see it's a 50/50 scene uh half of
the question chat G was able to provide
Solutions with and half of the questions
chat GPD couldn't actually figure out
what uh needs to be done even the logic
and approach was correct still the
implementation of the code was not
correct so let me search for
this question sum of
total strength of wizards again a hard
category question so let's have a look
at the question first let's C copy this
question uh create a new
chat paste it over
here and uh look for constraints now
that we have copied it paste it and
enter it's giving an approach how you
can actually uh think think of the
solution for this particular question
charge abity has not generated any code
uh let me ask for
it
okay so here's an example again they
have implemented the code in Python now
it is also giving a note that the
approach is valid only if you're allowed
to modify the original array and also we
are not working on down
way Manion and then write this code so
let's see if it can do it with self
argument okay so yeah there's an example
it's generating the code okay so let's
see what's the update with the
code
okay
this
are let's
add
solution and run the
code
so there's a runtime error let me see
why this
error and paste it over
here what charity have to say the error
message solution object has no attribute
mode so just that there is a class name
solution and the code is trying to
access an attribute named mod on an
instance of that class but attribute
doesn't exist we probably uh need to
make more specifications and if it still
doesn't works then it clearly classifies
that charity doesn't takes every point
or a classification uh you know in
consideration uh which
ultimately uh you know reflects on the
solution the new code is here let me
quickly paste
it
okay let's try running this code let's
see if this
works try running it
again and it has a runtime error I was
unable to solve one more question now
that we have tried and tested a huge
spectrum of questions from De code on
chat GPT we can conclude that though
chat gpts amazing tool with the bright
future it still has its own limitations
and maybe it is not ready to replace
humans or compete with human brains
these questions were picked from a list
of frequently asked questions for
interviews and examinations chat GPT
does have a potential to generate Logics
and approaches for the code in an
effective manner but still its ability
to analyze the question is weak as
compared to humans as we know these
questions are there the success rate
just shows that a proper solution to
exist for these question questions but
still even after multiple attempts chat
GPD was not able to find the correct
answer but we can also give chat GPD the
benefit of doubt that it's still it's in
in its initial phase and still there are
a lot of aspects that need to be worked
on so probably in future CH GP can
takeen upper hand over this but for now
CH GPD needs to do a lot of work for
these situations enhance your
professional prospects through
enrollment and post-graduate program in
Ai and machine learning from Simply
learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box and moving on
we'll start with our
project and for that first we'll create
a
folder in Python
projects and name it
as
telegram Port using chat JB
okay and inside this we'll open the Comm
prompt and open our ID that is I would
be using the visual studio code and you
can use any ID that you have and
on and
now we will go back to our chat jpd and
we'll start here but before that uh
let's talk about telegram board so a
telegram Bo is a program that interacts
with users VI the telegram messaging app
uh the prerequisite is you should have a
telegram account and Boards can be used
for a wide range of purposes such as
customer support news delivery and even
games and chj so chj is a large language
model trained by openi that is based on
gbt 3.5 architecture and J gbt is
capable of generating humanik response
resps through text based inputs making
it a great tool for building chat
boards and now if we talk about
prerequisits you should have a telegram
account python install on your system
and we need a python telegram board
library that I will show you what to
install and that CH J will tell us like
what to
install so we'll just ask CH
jity to
create telegram board
using
python okay so it says error we'll just
refresh the
page and ask again create telegram
board using python okay I see
what he States so create a telegram
board you need a on
telegram or talking to the board father
yeah we have to go to the board father I
will show you guys how to do
that install the required libraries next
you need to
install okay and write this
code
okay so in this
script they have started with the start
function so
it will just says
hello when it would be
started
okay so we'll add some more
functionalities
and we will ask uh where to find the
your API token here so I know like we
have to go to the word father but we
will ask chity
also where can we
find
theate
open so it states that to get to
telegram V AP token you need to create a
new boot by talking to the boarda on
telegram open telegram and search for
boarda Okay and send the boarda message
that is/ newb and the board father will
ask you for the name of the board and it
will ask you about the username and the
fifth is the boat father will then
generate a token for your boat this
token is a string of characters that
uniquely identifies your boat on
telegram so keep this token secure and I
will also blur it so you guys won't be
able to see it
okay so moving to our
telegram we'll just search board father
here and you can see this is the board
father and we'll just click on
start and they asked the J asked us to
right/ new board we'll just click on
this and we'll
get so all WR a new board how are we
going to call it please choose a name
for the
board so
right simply
learn underscore new
B
okay good let's choose an
username so
[Music]
simply
learn 1
onecore Port and it states that that
your usern name should end in BO so we
have to end it with Bo and you could see
see the token here and here you can just
access your
board so we'll get back to our ID and
create a new file and I will name it as
new. py only or you can name it as
board. py or anything you want we'll get
back to
our uh chity but before that first we
need to install the library for that you
can go to the command prompt or you
could use the terminal of your
ID that
is uh in Visual Studio code you you
could use the terminal to install the
libraries you could see that the
requirement is already satisfied as this
library is already installed on the
system so moving back library is
installed and now we'll copy this
code and paste it here
and we will just change the
token we'll go back to board
father we'll copy this
token come
back and paste it
here
okay now we will run this and see
whether our board is working or
not so it has successfully executed we
get back to our board further and just
click on simply onar one one board
so we click on
start and see it says hello I'm your
board so it's working fine so if we
write
hello it won't respond as there are no
functionalities so we will ask jity to
add
functionalities please add some
more
functionalities and
response to the
port
let's
see so sure here's an example of how you
can add some more
functionality so the used P updat
dispatcher
okay Define the help command
Handler
okay
so chat J has defined three functions
that is Eco and what does eco do it will
just give you the same thing what you
give to the board or what you write to
the board
caps that he has also declared a help
function and in which you can see like
what functionalities does the boat have
and the Caps will do it will convert the
message to all caps e uh e the message
back to you it will give you the same
message SL start it will start the board
and/ help to get
help and
now unknown uh if there's something you
ask out of these things it will just say
sorry okay I will let you guys
understand this code also but first
we'll see whether it's working or
not so for that we have pasted it here
and we'll paste our API topen
again
so I pasted it here now uh first we will
close this terminal and get a new
terminal and then run the
program we'll get back to the port
further and this is our Port so we'll
just write
slash
start and it says hello I your
board
now we'll
say hi to the
B so okay it's not
responding okay we just close the
terminal and we have pasted
the keys also
okay
run it
again now we'll see whether it's working
or
not
start
hi so the code is not
working just see theod
again
okay uh here we don't have any response
to I or lello so what we'll do we'll use
the help and to call the help what we
have slel so these are the commands for
what it will
respond so we'll use slash
help okay now you can see that SL start
to start the board that we have done
help and eco
EO the message back to you so we'll
write hi don't want write back so we'll
write slash equo
High then he has given us the output
that is hi so we can write slash
EO how are
you so it has given you back and same we
have slash caps so we'll write slash
caps and we'll write something in small
caps that would
be greatly
built okay now you can see it has
returned in
caps so you can add some more
functionality to it and before that I
will
get you guys understood the
code so now we'll see what does this
code do so first we have imported the
necessary modules that is the classes
from the python telegram board library
that we need to create our board so
telegram contains the main board class
while updator command Handler message
Handler and filters are classes that
that we use to handle incoming updates
and messages from
telegram okay now these are like uh we
have created an instance of the board
class that is using our telegram board
API token as well as an updat instance
that will continuously fetch new updates
from Telegram and pass them to the
appropriate handlers and we have used
context equal to true that tells the
updator to use the new context based API
introduced in version 12 of the python
telegram board library and we also used
a dispatcher object that will handle
incoming
updates after that we have created a
start function and passed update and
context so we have defined a function
that will handle the start
command and the update parameter
contains information about the incoming
update from telegram while the context
parameter contains some useful methods
and objects that we can use to interact
with the telegram API in this case we
have used uh context. port. send do uh
sendor message to send a message to the
chat with the ID specified by update.
effective chat.
ID and after that we have created a help
function so we use a multi-line string
to define the help message which
contains a list of available commands
and then we have used the context dobard
do sendor message to send the help
message to the
chat and after that we have the Eco
function so we use context. arguments to
get the message sent by the user after
the SL EO command so to use this we have
to use the/ EO and after that we have to
write the message and then use join to
join the message back together to a
single string we then uh we have used
the Conta text dobard do sendor message
to send the message back to the chat
then we have caps so this function
defines that will handle the Caps
command and we have again used the
context to arguments to get the message
sent by the user after the/ caps command
and then the we have used the upper
function to convert the message to all
gaps and then we have used the context.
board. sendor message to send the
message back to the chat then we have
unknown function
that is this function defines that will
handle any command that the board
doesn't recognize so we have used
context. port. send so it will just say
sorry okay so these are the start
Handler help Handler Eco Handler and
caps Handler so these are the
commands and we have the we have added
the ADD handl and to start the bo we
have used update do start _
poing so this is how we have created the
port with the help of python and
jity
so we are done with the project you can
add more functionalities also to the
board you can just ask CH jity to get
more functionalities to play music in
the telegram board or you could just ask
him how to send messages to a particular
user
by the board only and you could
also send media files ask the media
files from the board and you can train a
fully board by the help of Chad jpd and
this is called Chad jpd scripting so
with the help of Chad GP you can just
ask him and he will guide you with all
the code and processes you just have to
like make them in a sequence and use
them to full of your use
so for that first we'll open the command
prompt and run the file main for that we
write the command
gun main. go so this is the file that is
written in the go language and we going
to run with the command go run main. go
for that you need to have goang install
on your system so I will guide you with
all the process but currently we seeing
the demo
so here this command will generate a QR
code that will scan with the device
which we want to integrate the chat GPD
on so we'll wait for the file to get
executed and after this we will execute
the server.py file and that will open
the chat jpd on the Firefox browser you
can also use other browsers that is
chromium and other if you want but we'll
use Firefox
to skip the onstep verification that chj
ask us whether if we are a b or a human
so we'll run the file again as there was
some
error so this time yeah it run perfectly
now we'll take the device and open
WhatsApp on it in which we want to
integrate the chat jbd so I'm using one
device to just capture this QR code
so this is the device and you can see
that my device has captured this QR code
and you can see here that whatsap me
me it has been activated so now we'll
run another file that is server.py file
and that is the python file for that
we'll open the command prompt again and
that would be another command prompt and
to run that file we'll write the command
python
server.py
and you can see in the Firefox browser
CH jpt has opened and I have logged in
already so it didn't it didn't ask me to
log in
again now we'll take another device and
we'll message on the mobile device which
has been integrated with the
chity so from this device I will write
hi and you can see on the screen that
Chad JP replies hello how can I assist
you today and the same you could see on
the WhatsApp chat so today we will ask
chat JP what is the capital
of India so you can see that the chat JB
is typing the capital of India is New
Delhi and it has been responded to our
mobile device so this is
how we can integrate chat JP on a
WhatsApp and this would be the simple
tutorial in this you don't need to code
any uh this there would be another
tutorial if you know what's behind the
code or what behinds the integration
part so you could watch that video and
know how we have integrated but in this
tutorial I will guide you with how to
download the files and how to run the
files and how you can integrate chat
jity on your device so before proceeding
with the tutorial I have an insightful
for you
guys that is if you're aiming to get
certified as an AI and ml engineer and
want to build a career in AI in that
case you can check the Caltech
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning by simply learn which will open
the doors for the best career
opportunities and to find the details of
this course you can check the link in
the description box below and the pin
comments and we have a special discount
for our YouTube Community you guys can
Avail the course with a 15% discount by
applying a coupon code YT B15 on the
payment page and this coupon code is
also mentioned in the description box
and before starting let us have a simple
question to brush up on our
knowledge so I have a question for you
and your question is how much time did
open AI chat jpt took to hit 1 million
users so it's in days and your first
option is 9 days second option is 5 days
third option is 7 days and your fourth
option is 6 days please answer in the
comment section below and we'll update
the correct answer in the pin comment or
we will answer you directly in the
comments so you can pause the video give
it a thought and answer in the comment
section now now we'll move to start
integrating CH jpd on our device so for
that first you have to download this
repository and it contains some files
and I will upload some more files here
you just have to download it download
the zip
file and after downloading
it you just need to extract it in a
folder
so we'll extract in C drive in Python
projects mainly we create the folder
here only so here we'll create a
folder okay integrate chat what mean or
yeah right
integrate
chat GP that's it so inside this folder
we'll extract the files and I think it's
been done so we'll just
visit C drive uh python projects and
inside it we have integrate chat jity
and we have these two files so to run
these two files what you need is you
need python install on your system and
go length install on system so I hope
you guys know how to install Python and
goink if you don't I will just give you
a quick
tutorial so to download the python you
just need to visit the python.org
website and move to the download section
and you will see the download the latest
version for Windows you just need to
click that and the download will start
for you the package has been downloaded
so I will provide you the link on how to
download the python in the description
box and also the link for the GitHub
repository so you don't have to search
it anywhere also you can search it on
the browser just write integrate CH in
WhatsApp and abisara you will get the
GitHub link and just write GitHub also
in the search bar you will just
redirected to
this and now you have downloaded the
python so just open the exe
file and start with the installation so
you can choose at python. EXA to path
you can choose
that
and customize
installation and just tick on the python
test suit and the next you can add the
python to environment variables so you
have to take both these options and then
you will click on on the install as I
have already installed it so I won't
need to install it again you just need
to click on the install button and here
you will get the python installed
okay and the other thing you need is go
Lang go language so to download it you
have to go sorry you have to go to its
official website and go to the download
section and here you will see the
Microsoft Windows as I'm working on the
Windows operating system so I will
download for the windows I already
downloaded and installed it so you guys
can download it and I will show you like
this is simple how to install go you
don't need to add anything so it's been
downloaded okay to guide to the
installation okay so we are just waiting
for the setup to be initialized so that
we can install
it now you can see the next button is
available just click on that and a
previous version of go programming is
currently installed yes you can see that
it's already installed so you don't need
to do anything in installing the go
language just click on install and it
would be installed for you so I won't be
installing it again as I already
installed on my device so moving on now
what we'll do first we will run the
server. py file so for that we will go
to the folder where we have extracted
our files and here we will open the
command prompt and run the file
server.py so to run a python file we
have to write the command Python and
then the name of the file that is server
and its extension that is py so we have
initiated
that
okay uh Firefox is already running as we
have
not closed what we have opened for the
demo I think
uh there an error I
will
again run the command prompt I will just
close the previous command
prompts yeah I have closed them now I
will open the new one and you should
open the command prompt the new command
prompt after installing the Python and
the code language I will also assist you
in installing the GCC compiler because
you would be needing that for go
language so first
will run the server
file so you could see that by running
the python server.py file you could see
that that the chat jpd has opened up in
the Firefox browser so I will show you
the code what we need for that you need
to install the
flask system OS modules playright
module and here in the 16th line you
could see that we have used Firefox you
could use chromium for Chrome but the
case is you need to do the one step
verification that is the capture thing
for like initializing the chat jpd but
we don't need that so we are using the
Firefox so you should have Firefox on
your system now what I want you to do is
just install these modules as if you if
these modules would not be installed on
your system it would show an error it
would give you an error in the command
prompt only as I've already installed
them so it's not giving me any
error so I will tell you the commands to
install
them so to install flask you can just
write
pypi space flask in any browser and it
will direct to the
website so you could open the first link
that would be pp. RG and this is a
command pip install flask so you can
just copy that and open your command
promp first we'll create it contrl
C
and now you could see that we are in the
folder integrate chat jpd and here you
could paste this command and press
enter it states that that the
requirement is already satisfied as I
have already installed these modules and
the other module you need is play right
so just copy the command go to your
command prompt and paste this
command and press enter it would be
installed for you
and another module you need is virtual
environment so just copy this and paste
in your command prompt and another
module you need
is the OS module
OS SS system uh and we'll open the
pypi that is the official website the
PIP command website and you just copy
the command go to your command prompt
paste the command and press enter and
this module would also be installed for
you guys and now you have installed the
go language the Python language and the
modules you need to run the server.py
file now what you need to do is run the
go file but before running the goang
file what you need is GCC compiler so to
download it I will provide you the link
for the GCC or you could just see here
I'll provide you the link in the
descript description box below you could
just click on that you would be DED to
this page just click on this release
that was 24th Main and what you need to
download is this 64+
32bit just download it and as it gets
downloaded just open
it and click on the create
button and after that the second option
then next and the directory you want to
install in as I already installed
this I will
[Music]
choose the C directory
only in
C I
would install in Python projects
okay okay didn't took the the
folder and
see oh sorry cancel
it in Python projects and in the same
folder that was integrate chat
jbd okay so I'll will click on
next not time want to install it yes I
want to install here and when you click
on install it would get installed for
you guys I've already installed
it and the process started so it will
get installed
again so now what you have to do is you
have got the all the requirements to
integrate the chat jpd on whatsa that is
all the modules for the server.py file
and the main.go file for that you have
installed the go language and the GCC
compiler so you could run both the files
and for that
we will close the command prompts and
open the new command
prompts and this is
a folder so we will open one command
promp here
sorry and we have to open different
command prompts for both the files for
the uh goang file and the python file
okay
so we will open the command prom here
and now to run the goink file we need to
write the command go space run space the
name of the file and the extension that
is main. go and we have executed the
file and this file will provide us with
a QR code and we'll scan this QR code
from our first device in which we want
to integrate the chat jpd and before
that
we will run our another file that is
server.py file and for that we'll open
another command
prompt and to run this
command to run this file we'll write the
command python space the name of the
file that is server and the extension
py so we'll see whether a QR code is
generated or
not and I can see
e that it's been linked
to the previous device as we have done
in the demo so we haven't logged it out
so I will check with the device
yeah it's been active so I will just log
out from that
device and run it
again
or I will open another command prompt to
run the goang file
again so to run
it we'll open the command prompt and
write the command CMD for that and here
we write the command to run the go
file and we have done
that and if we see the server. py
file yeah it has been perfectly
executed uh but we not able
to yeah our chat jity is running fine
now what we have to do
is use our first device to scan this QR
code so that CH JP gets link to a first
device and then we'll use another device
to chat with the chat
jpd so now we have opened our first
device and open the WhatsApp and click
on the link
devices and
here we'll scan this QR
code and you can see that it's logging
in now it's logged
in and now from the another
device we'll ask a query to CH J and we
will ask Chad j to write a code to add
two
integers and that to
python so we just miss Spell python but
we hope that our J jpd understood that
so here we can see that the jge got the
command and it
has and a good example show here's an
example code to add two integers in
Python so you can see that chat jity has
been integrated and we'll
see its response yeah we got the
response and now we'll ask another
question and that would
be what is the currency of United
States let's see what it responds the
gry of United States is the United
States dollar it is the most commonly
used currency in international
transaction and in other words primary
Reserve currency so we can see that tell
it writes all the lines or
sentences it's been executed on the
browser and after it complains or it
stops generating the answer it sends it
to the whatsa
chat so here we are done with a
project now you guys have understood how
to integrate chat J with WhatsApp and
what you have done is you have
downloaded the repository and we have to
extract all all the files that are
present in the repository I will update
all the files you just have to extract
them into a folder and then run the
main.go file and the server.py file and
before executing these files you need to
have goang and python installed on your
system and for the python you need some
modules that we have seen that is the
playright module the flask module the OS
system module and the virtual
environment module so we have seen how
to install them and when then you will
just execute the file on the command
prompt you would get errors if these
files or modules are not installed on
your system and for goang we have
installed the GCC compiler and after
installing all these requirements then
you have to just run both the files and
when you run the goang file you will get
the QR code just scan it with your
device on which you want to integrate
that jpd and after that from any device
you can just message on that number on
which you have integ cre the chat GPT
and the chat GPT would answer all your
queries app so here we have chat GPT
okay you can write here chat.
open.com so here I will ask to chat what
is chat gity so I will here write what
is
chat
GPT so here you can stop generating if
you want to okay I will stop generating
Okay so jgb is a conversational
artificial intelligence model developed
by open a it is based on the GPD
generative pre-train transform
architecture specifically GPT 3.5 which
is at Advanced language model so GPT 3.5
is trained on a massive amount of Text
data to generate human like response to
wide range of prompts and question you
can ask anything to chat
gbt
okay after coming chat
GPT
software
developers are
safe software developers jobs are
safe like see yes after the introduction
of chat gity and similar language model
software developers still have important
roles and their jobs remain rent while
AI models like chat gbt can generate
text and provide automated response they
have limitations see they have
limitations chat gbt have limitation and
cannot replace the skills and expertise
of human software developers so here is
a few reasons why software developer
jobs remain valuable okay so here are
the few reasons so you can ask anything
to char gbt so what we will do we will
create a small small gaming app okay so
here I will write
uh let's make first Tic Tac do okay so
here I will
write give me the
code for
Tick T
to
game see it will give you the step by
step J will explain you everything see
this
board then player check columns check
diagonals play game everything see check
for the winner play
game I see to play the game simply run
the python script players will take
turns entering the row column numbers to
make their moves the game will okay so
what I will do okay first I will ask the
steps to make a game tic tac to
okay give me these steps to make Game T
to see first it will uh we will ask for
the steps then we will ask for the
code charity can make your app in 2 3
minutes in Just 2 3 minutes small small
app in 2 3 minutes okay see what what is
the first step set up the game board
create a data seure to represent the Tic
Tac to board this can be 3x3 Grid or
nested list with initial empty values
okay for example this then second is the
print the game board write a function to
display the current state of the board
on the screen this will help player
visualize the game and the third is get
player input prompt the player to enter
their moves accept the input for the
rows and columns where the players want
to place their symbol X or zero okay or
you can change the value X or zero
whatever cross right okay update the
board after receiving the player input
update the game board with their move
make sure to validate the move and check
if the selected position is empty okay
then check for the winner then check for
it is draw what then alternate
turns okay then repeat 2 to 7 until the
game sends optional add original
features we will first we will make Tic
Tac to
uh what you can say a simple Tic Tac
then we will add the additional features
on this okay using chgb only okay
so I will
write provide me
the t
t
to game
code what we will do we will uh open the
visual studio and copy it
directly okay see current player is X
then
o see current player R the second player
switch
player okay what we will do we will copy
it from here and we will open see Visual
Studio that new file I will write here t
t
to.py okay enter I will save it so here
I will directly copy the
code where is my code
oh it comes
in
okay copied this
also copy the whole
thing okay I have to remove this or I
can make it you know
comment
yeah so let's try to run it what
terminal
says see enter the row okay
two enter the column
two okay it made like
this okay what I will
do I will ask for the
GUI uh provide write me
The Tick T to game with
GUI okay now the Tinker came Tinker is
python Library used for the GUI in
Python okay okay now uh we'll copy the
code and just paste it it will run okay
with GUI and then we will add the
additional features okay from here now
I'm copying the code now select all
replace with this code like here no
error no red sign so let me play it it
will run I guess no
problems okay what happened see as you
can
see we got the Tic Tac toam okay so see
here x 0 x 0 x player X spin so let me
add the additional features in this so
what we will do we'll go to chat GPT
again we'll ask for the additional
feature see note the code above uses the
message box module from the Tinker for
displaying message ensure that you have
compatible version to thinker okay when
you run this code a graphical windows
will appear by 3x3 grip and this uh okay
players can click on the buttons to make
their moov the game state will
okay okay update you can you not talk to
charb so I I will say
update my code with some good font and
scoreboard
scoreboard font scoreboard and
color update my GUI code I can
write here is an update see right
certainly here is an updated version of
GUI code with improved font scoreboard
and color if you get error in this you
can ask to chat gbt
okay anything you are facing issue about
your code whatever it is you can ask
directly to chat
GPT see we created an App in like 2
minutes just in 2 minutes so chat gbt is
making our life
easier okay let me copy this
code okay let's see the changes what
what
J
does
okay there's nothing changed I
guess player X WIS like this
cross
okay
okay uh I will write here see in this
updated code the font style has been
improved with the Bold aial font the
buttons have a custom background color
and the overall window and scoreboard
have a different
color oh I didn't feel like
this I didn't feel like
this okay
so
[Music]
change uh
the grid style of the
game
it's giving updating the boat see to
change the great of the same you can
modify appearance of the buttons and the
spacing between them here is an updated
gii code with a modified Gest
St it's just a little bit of time taking
that's it nothing else it's very useful
jity you can create your app in 2 three
minutes only
okay continue generating it's a half
code okay code is
copied let me select and paste it here
and check
see player X zero player o
zero okay it's little bit different I
guess Max okay this one two three box
why these lines there okay who
cares clear xience okay see the
scoreboard is
updated okay
okay so this is how you can make your
Tic Tac Toe more
beautiful okay uh let me write
here let me write here I want the black
and white boxes okay or colorful boxes
so
code provide me the code for the
colorful
boxes
okay okay here chb wrote certainly here
is an updated version of the code with
colorful boxes instead of grid
lines
okay so wait waiting for the code update
code see in this updated code each
player's button X and O has a specific
color signed to it the button colors
okay let me copy the code and paste it
here and run
it see the color is changed here I will
write c x and o x o x o x layer
X okay so this is how you can make your
app more beautiful beautiful using
customization you can ask CH GPT
anything color style font or any
function anything you can ask and you
you can make your app more beautiful
entry-level jobs in cyber security field
requires you to trace track and defend
against cyber attacks on a day-to-day
basis you are required to enable systems
against all fraud land activity and
prevent any authorized access this
requires at length the need to write
scripts in various languages such as
plunk Java JavaScript python SQL PHP pow
shell and C amongst many others as
scripts grow in complexity so does the
time to write them ched GPD on the other
hand can create these complex queries
and scripts within split seconds along
with explaining them this can help save
hundreds of hours of effort for a cyber
security professional this is just one
such use case of how chat GPT is useful
in the field of cyber security although
relatively new the uses of chat GPT in
the field of cyber security is
innumerable from automating daily task
to script writing or endpoint detection
and if you want to know more about how
chat jpd can be used in the field of
cyber security and how I can change the
entire information security landscape
stay tuned with us until the end of this
video for some amazing information with
that being said welcome to yet another
amazing video by simply learn make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any other video
from us let us now quickly discuss the
agenda for the video we'll start with
knowing what is J proceeding we'll see
the uses of J in cyber security and
after that you'll have Hands-On lab
demonstration but before we begin if you
are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who alits to switch
careers in cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering the link is provided in
the description box that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered so let's start with our
topics and our first topic is what is
chat jity so chat J is an advanced AI
model chat Port that uses natural
language processing NLP to understand
and respond to user queries it is based
on the GPT 3.5 AR ecture and has the
ability to learn from conversations with
users making it more intelligent and
efficient over time chat gbd can be
integrated with various messaging
platforms such as flag and Microsoft
teams to provide a seamless and secure
communication experience so this was
about chat
GPT now let's understand the uses of
chat GPT in cyber security so users of
chat GPT for cyber security we'll start
with number one
we have threat detection and response so
chat GPD can be used to monitor network
activity and identify potential threats
by analyzing logs and data from various
sources chat jpd can identify unusual
patterns and Alert security teams it can
also provide real-time alerts to users
enabling them to take immediate action
to protect their data by using machine
learning algorithms chat JP can learn
from past incidents and continuous ly
improve its ability to detect new and
emerging threats once a threat has been
detected chat GPD can initiate an
automated response or cyber security
Personnel to take appropriate action
this can include blocking suspicious
Network traffic isolating infected
systems or disabling compromised user
accounts by providing real-time threat
detection and response chat jpd can help
organizations to minimize the impact of
cyber breaches and reduce edce the risk
of data loss or system downline it can
also help to improve overall security
posture by identifying vulnerabilities
and recommending proactive measures to
address them and the next we have is
password management one of the most
common ways that cyber criminals gain
access to sensitive information is
through weak passwords J jpt offers a
solution to this problem by assisting
users in creating strong passwords and
storing them securely with its Advanced
natural language processing capabilities
chat jpd can suggest complex and unique
passwords that are difficult for hackers
to guess moreover it can save these
passwords in an encrypted format
ensuring that they are protected from
unauthorized access another important
feature of chat G's password management
tool is the ability to remind users to
change their passwords regularly this is
crucial as it helps prevent the use of
outdated passwords that can be easily
hacked and at number three we have
employee training
many cyber attacks are caused by human
error such as clicking on fishing emails
or using weak passwords chat jity can be
used to provide employee training on
cyber security best practices with its
ability to simulate real life scenarios
it can create interactive training
modules that help employees learn how to
identify and respond to cyber attacks
for example it can provide simulation of
fishing emails where employees can learn
to identify the warning signs and avoid
clicking on M ious links or downloading
harmful attachments next up we have
Incident
Management Incident Management is an
essential part of cyber security as it
involves the process of identifying
assessing and responding to security
incidents that threaten an organizations
information or technology Assets in
today's digital age cyber attacks have
become increasingly common and
sophisticated making Incident Management
even more critical one of the ways chat
GPT can help progn ganizations with
Incident Management is providing
stepbystep instructions on how to
contain the attack mitigate the damage
and restore normal operations when a
security incident occurs Tim is of the
essence and organizations need to act
fast to minimize the impact of the
attack jgpt can help by providing
real-time guidance on how to respond to
incident effectively and the next we
have is compliance management many
Industries are subject to Regulatory
Compliance requirements such as HIPAA
and PCI DSS these requirements ensured
that organizations adhere to certain
standards and regulations in order to
protect the privacy and security of
sensitive information failure to comply
with these regulations can result in
Hefty fines and reputational damage J
GPD can play significant role in helping
organizations ensure compliance with
these regulations with its ability to
process large amounts of data in real
time it can provide alerts and guidance
on best practices and generate
compliance reports this can help
organizations identify areas where they
may be falling short of compliance
requirements and take corrective
measures to address
them and now we'll move to Hands-On
demonstration but before moving let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers by taking our courses so
just hear to them hi I'm Philip I'm 61
years old and last year I upskilled with
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the it sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before as a security analyst
and architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with infosis as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and now first we'll see what is chat GPT
you could just write chat GPT on web on
any browser and this is the website
where you will cling and this is the
website for
Char so you could see the samples here
and what the user has asked is this code
is not working like I expect how do I
fix it so he has pasted the or input the
command to chat jpt and pasted his code
and chat JP will has answered that it's
difficult to say what's wrong with the
code without more
context so this is how chat jpd responds
and when you just click on here try chat
jpd you will have the window here so
this is the J gbt window and here we'll
start with some Hands-On lab
demonstration for our cyber security
like how Chad GPT can help us in cyber
security field so we'll start with the
basic questions and we'll see what he
answers us he or she answers or what
jadj answers us so we'll start with the
basic question
explain the mitm
tech okay
uh for
beginers so we'll see what it
responds certainly a man in the middle
attack is a type of Cyber attack where
an attacker secretly intercepts and
possibly Alters the communication
between two parties without the
knowledge the attacker positions
themselves between the two parties hence
the term man in the middle okay okay he
has given us a very good
definition and here's a simple
explanation of
okay and I want to ask
him can you
explain this to a
OR7 year old
kid so we'll see how chat GPD
can mitigate or just try to understand
this concept to a
7-year-old so he has answered us that's
sure imagine you and your friend have a
secret way to send messages to each
other using a special code you both
trust and only you two can understand
the messages but one day someone sneaky
sneaky comes in between you and your
friend without you knowing they secretly
listen to your messages and even change
them without you realizing it it's like
they're hiding and watching your
conversation this sneaky person can
pretend to be you when talking to your
friend can pretend to be you
okay so he has taken the good
example and they can also PR to be your
friend when talking to you so you might
think you're talking to your friend but
actually you talking to a sneaky person
the sneaky can do bad things like
stealing your SE changing to take you
spy who can listen to everything you say
and even change you he has taken a very
good example to get this concept clear
to us 7-year old G really
impressive so we will ask him some more
questions and we'll ask the last basic
question that would
be what is
SQL injection and after that we could
ask him some code
Snippets what is SQL injection
and
provide a real life
sample to understand the concept so you
have to write these prompts and you have
to be very specific and you can follow
up with your prompts also when J jpd
answers you you can follow up him and
ask him more about it as I have done
here first I have asked him explain the
IMM attack for beginners and he has
given me the definition that is
technically and now I have asked him can
you explain this to seven-year-old kid
and he has answered me with a very good
example similarly you can do the
follow-ups for any PRS so now I'm asking
Chad j what is SQL injection and provide
a real life example to understand it for
a
big and let's see what CH gy answers us
so SQL injection is a type of C attack
when attch experts m in a website so he
is giving us the
technical
definitions okay impressive is's also
telling us here how the attack might
work
okay and he has also suggested us to
protect against SQL injections
developers need to implement proper
security measures so this is the attack
that is on the database that you can
read here or if you know that is very
good we are just checking how Chad GPD
responds or give answers we are not
implementing or like we will asking the
code Snippets but we will not be able to
implement in this video we are just we
are here to just check out what chat GPT
provides us for cyber security
field
so you can
see he has given us a very good response
and moving on now we will ask him
uh to generate a CTF challenge that
contains an SQL injection let's
see what it
answers so you could see that Char is
responding to us that is show here an
example of a CTF that is kept to the
flag challenge that involves and SQL
injection
vulnerability challenge title product
search Okay challenge description
welcome to the product search challenge
you have access to an online store
search feature you can find products by
typing keywords your task is to exploit
and SQL injection vulnerability to
retrieve hidden information okay and he
has challenge code retrieve the admin
password from the database and challenge
instructions with the challenge website
find the search box and start searching
the go to
expect okay so we could see the example
solution let's assume the website search
functionalities vable vulnerable to SQL
injection you can try and putting the
following in the search box okay
explanation the injected SQL statement
query to always evaluate to True
semicolon have ter the original query
and the Comm out when you execute the
search the modified query might look
like okay
so it is like what response he has given
is very nearby you can have the followup
commands if you want something from him
so we are just checking what it provides
so he has given a very impressive
answer like truly speaking a very
impressive answer so moving on we'll ask
him some other questions
so okay I will ask him how can I
[Music]
scan and I can scan for SM
vulnerabilities with nmap so I will ask
him that
only and that is with
map so let's
see so to scan for SMB you can utilize
nmap scripting engine and a specific SMB
script here's how you can do it okay he
has given us the steps
also so you could see how chat jpt
guides you to every process you
need so first we have to install the N
map and you guys if you are willing to
implement this you can implement this he
has given you all the
steps I won't be implementing as I'm
just quing the chat jpd how he can
answer the
questions so install and map and I then
identify Target and then we have to run
this n map with SMB script
okay okay that's good and then review
the
results it's very impressive how chj
answers to these
questions and now I want him to give me
a code example to check user input for
no SQL
injection
so show me a code
example to check user
input and that would be for no SQL
injection see certainly when it comes to
preventing no SQL injection the key is
to properly
sanitize and and validate user input
before using it in database queries okay
that's good and the specific approach
may very depending on the programming
language and database system you're it
okay but here's a general code example
in JavaScript using nodejs and be
okay
okay and function
input and okay uh this thing the chat
jpt has done is very good he has
explained the whole code like if a
beginner wants to learn and wants to
have some queries resolved he can just
see like what the function are doing and
what this code really means so in this
example we have sanitized input function
that receive user input and applies an
necessary sanitization or validation
logic to prevent no SQL
injection it's very good so you could
just copy and use the code and if it
gives you error you can just have follow
questions
that we'll just ask him this code might
have some
error can you
Rectify so let's see what jge answers us
apologies for any confusion cost here's
an updated code example that addresses
potential errors and clarifies the
usage and you could see that he has
given
us a little I don't think he
is okay he has changed something and he
has provided us updated
code okay yeah there are
some changes I've seen okay so in this
updated code the DB connection is
closed this is the change here
and username and perform save query
function now includes a try catch okay
like if there is any exception or
something so he has updated the code if
you guys quote any error you could just
paste the error here and ask him to
rectify it so chity is very good for
cyber security I
think and moving on we'll have some more
like queries for chity and we'll see how
it will
respond so we'll write a
query
M okay we can ask him to filter IP using
spunk spun okay so okay
right regular
expression and plunk to filter
I let's see
so to filter IP addresses using regular
expression and slun you can use the reex
command okay yeah you have to use
that that matches IP before
addresses okay this good and you would
see that he has explained what the
script means so Rex a command used for
extracting field based on regular
Expressions field equal to row specify
that we want to apply the regular
expression to the row field which
contains the row loog data that is very
good so CH is giving us answers like a
pro
so we could also ask a spun query uh to
data command and control Bing activity
using subdomain DNS
request so for that we'll write WR a
plunk
query
to
detect
command and
control cing
activity and that would be using
subdomain DNS
requests okay let's see so to detect
command and control that is C2 beoning
activity using subdomain DNS requ and
you can use theowing
Query okay very good so J J has answered
this also and he has also shown us
here's how the query works and the qu
will display the domains and he has
stated what it will show as the out
output so he has also told you that is
make sure to replace your index your
Source type and threshold with the
appropriate values for that environment
that's very good so you could use this
and Implement many things in cyber
security I'm very impressed with it so
we will ask him one or two more queries
and I also want to check I will give him
a code and let's see if he can find Find
the Errors in that or not as we have
seen on the chat JB page
okay so what we can ask him now is like
we can ask him the script to get
malicious IPS from s and block it on my
firewall
okay so we'll ask him generate the
script to get malicious
IPS
that is from
cm
and
blocket on my
firewall okay so to generate a script
that redes malicious IPS from s that is
security information and even management
system and blocks them on your F you
will need to integrate your SM with your
firew good and use the appropriate apis
or commands for by your fire word
here's an example of a high level script
that demonstrates the
concept okay so we just
see okay he has provided us uh good
script and please note that this is a
generic example and the actual
implementation will depend on your
specifics s and firewall system yeah
this is correct and you'll need to
replace yeah you have to replace and
then sure that you understand add to
documentation and guidelines provided by
SCM and Fir venders for integrating and
blocking IPS
good so you could see like how he is
helping
us and
now I will ask him a last command and
yeah and after that we'll ask him to get
extracted some errors from a particular
code and that code would be simple
only so can ask
him a Shell Code that would execute
cmd.exe
okay generate Shell
Code that
executes cmd.exe
okay I'm sorry but I can't assist with
generating Shell Code that executes
arbitrary commands or facilitates any
malicious activities my purpose is to
provide helpful and responsible
information to users okay so you can
trick him to give you these but I think
he has been functioned to not provide
these so no
issue uh we'll ask him to generate a
macro see if he responds to that
generator
macro that
executes CMD
doc let's
see okay so it won't give us this answer
I apologize but I won't be able to
generate a macro that executes cmd.exe
or facilitates any potential harmful
activities my purpose is to provide
helpful and responsible information to
users if you have any any other
malicious questions or need assistance
with a different topic feel free to ask
and I will be glad to assist you okay
guys so I think it won't respond to this
and now I will ask him to
rectify some errors and give us the
perfect code and I will provide him a
code so I'll ask
him and
right a working
code this code
snippet okay so let's
see certainly there are a couple of
issues in the provided code snippet and
here's the rectified
version okay I know
like oh yeah I didn't pass data I miss
the brackets also
here and let's see what he has given us
so the
line modifi to yeah he has passed the
data columns and is connected
to
okay I didn't know that was the error
also rectified code now properly reads
the file data calculates the md5 hash
and returns it please ensure to provide
the correct file path and file path okay
that's very good so I think this is for
it and we have tested the chat GPD how
he can help in like who wants to pursue
in cyber security so we can get the
answers we can write the codes and in
upcoming videos we can just make a
project using this uh we could have a
password
generator and I know the CH jpt is a
tool which will help us in every field
and in cyber security field it is
helping us a lot and yeah to some
questions it doesn't
answer like that is for the security
purpose or the script shouldn't be used
for malicious activities so that's why
the software has been programmed for
that enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment and postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box AI art and chat
GPD can be used to create unique and
creative web design by combining the
power of artificial intelligence and
human input with AI art you can generate
visually stunning Graphics patterns and
images while chat jbt can be used to
generate text content and provide
suggestions for website layouts and
design element so hey everyone you're
already watching simply learn and today
we bring you this informative video on
charity for UI and ux before we begin if
these are the videos you like to watch
then hit the Subscribe button and the
bell icon to get notified every time we
upload a new video without any further
delay to get started you can experiment
with different air tools to generate
graphics and use chat GP to write
website copy create a Content strategy
and provide feedback on Design Elements
it's important to keep in mind that
while AI can help to generate ideas and
create stunning visuals I'm going to
show you exactly how you can generate te
yourself websites are going to be built
with AI art as well as tools like chat
GPD in future so in this video I'm going
to explain the whole process and we are
going to have it write the entire
Website Layout for us all the content
the hero section and feature section and
much more this means that we can build
an entire website from the ground up
without writing a single line of code
and this will be a pretty damn gool all
right we will start with the mid journey
in Google search we will write
M
Journey this is an AI tool that allows
you to create the AI art that we are now
seeing all over the web to go to this
you just go to the mid journey.com and
join the beta it's easy to get started
because all you really have to do is
join the Discord when you do this it
will open up the Discord Community which
you can accept the terms and condition
and start creating your own AI Arts
let's do this now
here I have got the mid Journey server
and I'm going to head over to one of the
newcomer room here and and where
everyone is creating different types of
AI art the first thing we need to do is
or to do a forward slash and type in an
imagine give us prompt
for
we can uh request the AI any type of art
we are after here I'm going to type uh
in a
beautiful
website
for
shoe then I'm going to pass in dash
dash V4 which means uh the version four
of the mid journey of air tool finally
I'm going to pass it in style stylize
I'll do dash dash stylize it's basically
how random we want to be in uh it's
between 0 to th000 and I'm just going to
set it to about 500 which is average so
I will do the enter it will take a
little bit of time here this will start
working in the background it's going to
generate a low Fidelity version of the
website and the design for this art and
this low fidelity version will be
iteratively updated to be higher in
resolution these four examples then can
be picked from and then we can upscale
them as well as uh let's have a look at
what kind of results we get now one
thing uh to notice here is that we do
get a bit of a loading percentage bar
and this is how long it takes for the
actual AI to generate the image uh
usually takes between 1 to 2 minutes but
it will essentially refresh and ping you
once it's complete so here is it is
complete and here are the four versions
that we got which are not too bad uh not
that great either they are bit uh yeah I
suppose it's looking a funny in a way so
this is where we can start being more
creative with our prompts so what I mean
that uh is by giving more context as to
what we want to do so here is a prompt
that we have created what I'm going to
do is to pass it in the imagine once
more and I paste this prompt in this and
I'm going to give some more context I'm
going to pass it to the word youi wa
choose UI
ux UI ux website this basically means
that it's more or less focused on having
good UI and good at ux and being more
like a website rather than just a
creative shoe or a design and it's
important to give these context clues to
the AI if you want better outputs
different types of uh context clues you
can provide is to find a kind of style
that you want uh for for example um how
you want the design to look and feel
whether you wanted to represent a
certain brand or much much more like
these are just simple examples but let's
take a look at the kind of results we
will get just from making these small
little changes to the design here here
you can already see uh wait a minute
look it's a little bit more interesting
we have a bit of our sliders and what
looks more like a Nike shoes and also
have uh uh what looks like a menu at the
top and and I really like this uh design
uh that we have here on the bottom and
here it is because it does look very
much like a website that we have got a
bit for a hero section or a hero set
section and what's not so from here we
can select the version one uh so from
here uh we can select uh the version 1 2
3 uh 4 to upscale and I'm going to
upscale version three where which is u3
and this will give us a higher
resolution version of this one
particular design that we can uh that we
can start to take uh to the market or
even you can use to build this again uh
will take a little bit of time it's
going to process this and uh to do and
you can upscale in data and let's run
this in the background so that you can
see uh oh wait a minute this again will
take a little bit time to process it's
going to process this and do an UNSC or
upscale in beta and let's run this in
the background so that you can guys see
what's the look so here's the final
result and this is looking uh pretty and
we have got the nice design here here
for a shoe uh we have got a bit of a
hero section and we also have what looks
uh like a two call to actions and we got
some option here to at the very bottom
and as well as at the top we have got
these colors and that essentially are
looking like these shoes colors being
used as a part of the website design so
not too shoy uh let's select uh the
another one let's see
for yeah
uh but I think we can do a little bit
more um in terms of customization the
design for this website and I'm going to
show you how you can do this I'm going
to copy over this uh prompt once and for
this prompt this time I'm going to pass
a couple of extra things so let me just
uh maximize
this
we are going to type um as I have uh
pasted that URL over here so I'm going
to pass uh in the context clues of like
uh clues of Nike because Nike made
obviously website showes so
also uh so we'll write it
here my
key right
here repeat and I also I want it to be
red
blue
green
and or uh maybe uh
yellow and I suppose uh we want to uh
else uh running
person would be
interesting sorry
person uh it would be interesting to see
how that gets designed uh and I think
that this should be enough let's
actually improve the styling here uh 1
minute let's change the styling
let's let's have it
750 uh to make it a little bit more
creative and here are the results I
don't have a running person but I do
have a website that has definitely
started using the colors that I
recommended uh with Jour AI art systems
to use so these website designs look way
more creative than we had previously
still we have this slider design these
website designs look way more creative
than we had previously we still have
this slider design here at the bottom
section where we can pick out different
shoes but even these shoes look damn
cool I can see that the Nike logo on
these and these are actually ones that I
would probably buy if I saw in the Nike
store but generally uh these also are
website because we have got the menus
here at the top of the right uh we got
the text so generally speaking uh these
are pretty interesting interesting
designs so now I have another option
here called version one 2 3 4 what this
does is actually allow you to pick uh
more Generations uh based on a actual
image from these images or these designs
now from these design I actually like
the 12 three and four I think it is most
I think four cuz uh it teals and red or
it's a bit yellow or blue so I'm going
to select the version um four and that's
going to create uh four more version
based on the specific version for us
let's take a look at the what those that
we got and here we have got our
results uh where we have more examples
of that all of these looks very similar
I think the only difference here is uh
Blue Line a red line it seems to be
shift and change as well as a hero
section and and you would normally have
this menu at the top right and something
these shoes here are a little bit
inverted but generally speaking this is
the kind of variations you can
expect now let's take a look at another
way we can generate Our Generations for
website now you can do is just uh jump
into any website and select any image so
first we will go to an app and website
and you can uh select any image that you
would like and I will actually gone
here and I'm going to pull in this image
of this shoe and but I do like the
design Aesthetics uh here we are going
to here and then we can copy the URL
from here but this time what I'm going
to do is type the
imagine
imagine then I'm going to pass uh in the
URL what we have copy uh we will paste
it
here again I'm going to
write we did it before we'll copy
this paste it over
here so what's going to happen here it's
uh it's going to have a look at this
image that we have defined in in terms
of the URL it's going to use this as a
reference point then it's uh going to
take a look at the prompt we have poon
which is the Sho prom using the colors
and it's going going to try to
design a website that has a similar
Aesthetics to that image which is really
cool let's see the result we get back
looks like uh that's ready uh let's take
a look at this so here you can see that
the design is
Statics uh wait a minute static uh that
is uh similar to the page seen in this
one
so this is more bubbly and colorful
image and now I represented very much so
in this design
Aesthetics uh we have these four
elements here at the bottom and if you
have a look at the design originally uh
we had four elements here so you can see
that it's pulling in these design
Aesthetics to create a design based on
that and this is where you can really
start using the air art repeat using the
air tool to your own benefits trying to
combine different styles customizing
them and creating new and independent
and unique ones from there so in this
four I'm really like uh uh the version
of fourth one or the second one is uh
pretty so uh what I'm thinking of doing
is an upscale on this so we are going to
upscale uh V2 and we are going to wait
for the that uh one minute is uh use
chat CPD to write out the most of the
content for me and then I would I could
take this to a client to immediately
start sailing so let's see the upscale
version happen if we take a uh closer
look we will see that it has all the
main elements for a website including a
logo area uh a menu area a nice hero uh
image as well as a title tagline Button
as well the feature section
so what I'm going to do is to save this
image to my computer I'm going to save
it and then customize it a little bit
but before we do that uh we are going to
head over to at
GPD here we going to prepare the outline
for the website using some AI tools so
here I'm going to ask CH GPD to give me
the broad Brad
outline for for a website for
shoes including hero
title
tagline call to action button and
section for features and details about
the shoe so let's see what tability will
comes back with um it's pretty quick uh
it's got a title here call to action
button features and detail section and
it's not really telling me what these
are these are where we might need to be
a bit more specific as to what we wanted
to do it's giv me uh it's giving me like
broad outline of the website on what it
needs so please I will
write please
provide
then for each one of these that I can
copy
paste
straight to the
website um hero title is here tagline
call to action
buttons
features
okay
and the
details okay details specification is
there okay reviews and
rating
okay so I think I have got enough hairs
to go by to Simply copy paste and the
website so let's start beginning to
design this I have opened this
design up in the Photoshop and I'm going
to actually just drop it into the main
element over here and I really want to
capture
this image and I will crop it and I will
clear out the rest and we can design
each aspects or each part of this
design bit by
bit I will save it over
here it's time to build our website so
I'm going to head over to add l
x and I'm going to build this uh a
website in this I have login already and
then I will create to a new site and
here I will takeen to a web uh dashboard
and I'm going to start by copy copy
paste all the elements from chat gbd as
well as mid Journey straight and the
first thing and I want to jump back into
the chat GPD here and copy of our hero
text so I will just take it
first and I'm going to T add title and
I'm going to paste it over
here and then I'm also going to grab the
tagline but before I will make it sure
to keep keep it over
here but before
that I will first I will put one image
over
here I will change the
image as I have already uh downloaded
the image
let's upload that
image we'll open it and let's wait to
get
uploaded yeah it's uploaded and now we
will update
it let's make it big in
size okay so we
will we will change the size but first I
will remove this I will change the size
for this I will make it little
small next I will add the icon
for uh for the company of the showes
that we I'm going to make a website for
I will add this and I will update
it make it
small
and this will be the taskar
but make the size uh small a bit and
we'll insert one more picture
and it will be the logo of the company
that we are going to put over
here we will minimize it we can resize
it can
keep keep the logo over
here
now next uh then I'm going also going to
grab the tag line over here so I'll
the I'll pick this
tag I will add the
text comes up over
here okay make it small in
size and we will paste
[Music]
on
and finally Let's uh grab a call to
action which says
sh and create a button button for that
so so here we have all the workings of
what we uh at least what we would need
at least so for for the
content let's resize this
first
now we will add uh we need to add the
image itself so instead of just having a
browser stock images or anything like
that we actually had our images either
done inside of the photoshops that we
have done before as from the mid Journey
as well as so I'm going to just
drag the image
and I'm going to change the
image and it should be here I've already
download it no I have to upload it I
have a collections of
some shoes uh let's
see
and I will just install when I'll upload
this
picture it will take a bit of time let's
wait for a
while and once it's uploaded we
will we will update
it add
it's keep it like
this or we
can
so uh we change our content place from
that to make it a fix in a place so here
we
can change this
also a pretty
well
okay
so basically have this text happening a
little bit
more
here we have seen how we can resize it
from this scroll bar
and
so now let's add one more uh picture
over here to make it look more
better let's take a picture from
here change the
image upload
from
[Music]
computer valid
form
no we will upload it I can
sorry
and we'll update
it resize
it let's turn it
on
Let's uh make a task barar for the top
top most of of the screen we will have a
homepage so we will write a text over
here that will
be make it small a bit in
size
we'll add another
text it it will show about
us it will show about a section so we
write it over
here this small
into
let's make same
size make more
small alarm let's make it more small
alarm Okay uh the next next session will
be
services
and the last one is context one
section
one more option is
there uh that is a start button like uh
we are keeping the start button over
here so we will we are keeping this here
so let it be
here
yeah so next uh what I'm going to do I'm
going to
select add uh section and I'm going to
just have a blank
section um here I'm going to do first I
will add a picture first as a
background let's do it I will add one
picture let's see I have downloaded or
not I'm going download it wait a minute
uh Let It Be
[Music]
upload I will update
it that would be a whole for a whole
page
so
let's add the pictures now for another
shoes here's the
picture I'm going to we open this I
put
this
okay I'll update
it to add
it
keep the pictures over here like
similarly we will upload three pictures
over
here
after this let keep it
here's keep this
here
we are going to add another title over
we are making it a bit
it we will change the font for this
let's make
this after this I we will start editing
the features of the shoes
let's go to chat
G let's take this
first
paragraph
make it
small make it
B
we will add another paragraph over
here
similarly we will make it for this
also
and last we will
add a contact
us last we will add a contact a section
over here
again
so this is the final
output of chat GPD or how we use chat
GPD an AI art for a UI and you designed
to create a website or a web page or the
land page for the
shows started artificial intelligence
large language models and AI chat Bots
have come a long way and today we have
many AI language models which are
helping us throughout various domains
few examples are Microsoft
Google's Bard open AI chat GPD Megatron
T5 and many more today we will be
discussing about the caliber of chat gbd
and AI which can leverage you and help
you to build a perfect business so few
of the reasons that you need to consider
are the decision making capabilities of
chat GPT and AI customer services that
you can offer through chat GPT and AI
chat GPT potential to create content and
its potential to leverage data analysis
and chj is and AI capabilities to
provide sales and marketing for you and
run automation for you we will discuss
each one of these in detail so the first
one is decision- making capabilities of
chat GPD in terms of raw processing
speed chat GPD can analyze and generate
text at a rapid Pace capable of
processing and generating responses much
faster than a human can type or think it
can quickly access and retrieve
from its pre-trained knowledge providing
intermediate answers to suggestions
therefore chat GPT excels in processing
and generating text at higher speeds
however it cannot be directly compared
to humans in terms of decision making
abilities however it is proof that it is
90% accurate in decision making whereas
humans tend to be accurate at a rate of
80 to 85% CH GPT is anyways stronger in
terms of decision making at this case
followed by that moving ahead to the
next reason that is the customer service
that chat gbd and AI can help you with
if you compare a human the customer
support representative reads the
customer care compared to human the
customer support representative has to
read a customer's query analyze the
problem and formulate a response this
process may take a few minutes or more
depending on the complexity of the issue
and represent
typing speed right but when you compare
it with chat GPD the AI power chatbot
like chat GPD quickly scans and
comprehend the customers's query it
generates a response within milliseconds
providing intermediate assistance as
well so chat gbt is proficient at
providing customer services at a much
faster rate and it can also eliminate
you the cost of hiring training and
maintaining an entire Army of customer
service
moving ahead we have content creation if
you are a startup company or a company
which needs content creation for your
product then obviously you might end up
hiring Freelancers or a team of content
creators right but compared to humans
chat GPD is proficient at generating
content and can produce coherent and
contextually relevant text so you can
even save money by using the most
powerful and fully operational AI model
to create more versatile and highly
qualified content for you to avoid
hiring Freelancers and employees now
moving ahead the next reason is using AI
models for business data analysis AI can
assist you in data analysis by
leveraging its computational power and
advanced algorithms to possess and
extract valuable insights from large and
complex data sets AI algorithms can
automate data cleaning pattern
recognition and anomaly detection tasks
enabling faster and more accurate
results a a models can also perform
Predictive Analytics identifying Trends
and making forecast based on historical
data additionally AI can facilitate data
visualization presenting information in
intuitive and interactive formats for
better understanding by automating
repetitive tasks and augmenting human
capabilities AI enhances the proficiency
efficiency accuracy and scalability of
data analysis procedures you can rely on
AI language model to extract transform
and load data and analyze your business
data generate reports draw projections
and make data driven decisions to help
grow your company and this also Awards
you to hire and maintain a huge Army of
data analyst which may produce some of
the other errors in real time right and
next reason is sales and marketing chat
GPD can leverage sales and marketing
efforts in the following ways custom
customer engagement chat GPD can engage
with potential customers in real time
answering their queries providing
product information and guiding them
through sales process it enhances
customer experience by delivering prompt
and personalized responses next is lead
to generation chgb can act as a virtual
assistant collecting and qualifying
leads by interacting through website
visitors it can gather relevant
information access customer needs and
provide initial assistance generating
valuable for the sales team 24/7 support
chat gpt's ability to operate Around the
Clock allows for continuous customer
support it can address inquiries offer
product recommendations and resolve
issues even outside regular business
hours improving customer satisfaction
and retention now instead of hiring a
team and manually marketing your product
on social media platforms and spending
thousands of dollars to run paid
marketing you can use AI models to crack
the algorithms and Market the product to
your target audience with that let's
proceed to the next reason that is
automating your tasks chat GPT can
automate business procedures in the
following ways the first one being
customer service chb can handle customer
inquiries Provide support and resolve
common issues through automated chat
interactions it reduces need for human
intervention saves time and enables 24/7
customer support lead qualifications
chat gbt can engage with potential
customers ask question qualifying
questions and and gather information to
assess their suitability as leads it
automates the initial stages of lead
qualification enabling sales team to
focus on most promising prospects only
next is data entry and processing chat
GPD can automate data entry task by
extracting relevant information from
various sources such as forms emails or
documents it reduces manual effort
improving accuracy and speeds up the
data processing appointment scheduling
chat GPD can integrate with scheduling
systems allowing customers to book
appointments or schedule meetings
automatically finally workflow
automation chat GPD can integrate with
business systems and automate workflows
it can initiate actions send
notifications or trigger processes based
on predefined rules streamlining
operations and improving efficiency by
automating various tasks and processes
CH gbd enhances productivity reduces
operation cost and frees up human
resources for focusing on higher value
activities with their business so these
were the few important ways and reasons
why chart GPT and AI can help you make
your business if you looking for ways to
generate passive income without putting
in too much effort thanks to the
advancement in artificial intelligence
and chat boards it's now possible to
earn money using these Technologies in
this video we'll explore some of the
effective ways to generate passive
income with JJ CH je is known for being
the world's smartest generative Ai and
is changing the game when it comes to
making money online with this
revolutionary free tool you can earn
with little skill and no Capital
required there is an exciting New Era of
artificial intelligence and now is the
perfect time to get involved and take
advantage of this opportunity people are
using chat J for YouTube blogging
freelancing and for many other ways to
make money so let's dive in and discover
how to make money using chat J and
generate way passive incomes there are
variety of ways that you can make money
using CH je we'll discuss few of them in
this video and we'll start with first
we'll see the list of all the ideas from
which you can make money the first is
get business ideas from Chad jity second
is freelancing third is build a software
fourth is boost your affiliate marketing
with Chad je email expertise fifth is
leverage Chad je for blogging success
the next is unlock the potential of chat
J for affiliate marketing and then we
have utilize chat J for ebook writing
and self-publishing this is the main
thing what people are doing to make
money using chity and then we have
utilize chity to enhance your YouTube
channel and then we have writing lyrics
for music so starting them one by one
we'll start with get business ideas from
chj by getting to know your interest
talent and obstacles jadj can generate
tailored business Concepts that align
with your expectations let's Dive Right
In and ask JJ for some business ideas
for a computer science engineer who has
experience in digital marketing and
sales chat jity and ask him that I
am computer science graduate or computer
science
engineer with experience in sales and
marketing and what side
hustle should I
start
generate around
$1,000 generate
$1,000 income that would be per
day and that would be with minimum
investment I
want n is
not day with minimum
investment and I can also tell him how
many hours I can dedicate so I can
dedicate 8 to 10 hours okay uh 8 to 10
hours to this side as
well press
Center so you could see that chat jpt
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with spens and sales and
marketing the several side of sales to
generate ,000 income per day and he has
stated the first one is e-commerce then
affiliate marketing digital products you
can create and sell digital products
such as ebooks okay freelancing social
media management and YouTube channel you
can start your YouTube channel so these
are the ideas that you can get from Chad
j and what these ideas tailored to user
skills and interest that I have put in
now it's time to take these ideas and
discuss them further with Chad jpd to
conceptualize a plan so consider
important factors like alternatively you
can begin by stating generate a new
business idea for digital products you
can write that and he will guide you how
you can start it or you could just
write can you
elaborate the
business
idea of
digital products
I
want to start the side hustle like
this and then you press enter and you
can see that it has
started the process for the business
idea certainly starting a side hustle
centered around digital products can be
lucrative and fulfilling Venture
identify your expertise it Manu areas of
knowledge skills and passion and then he
has stated choose your product format
create valuable content set up an online
platform Market your products build an
audience optimize for conversions
provide excellent customer support so
these are the parts he has stated and
moreover you can elaborate those parts
also you can just ask chat depy so how
can I identify my expertise and he will
guide you with that so you can go deep
down and and explore any business idea
so this was the first method through
which you can generate income from jgb
and moving on the next would be
freelancing so take your freelancing
game to the next level with ch jity this
stateof the-art AI tool is enabling
professionals to an extra income and
produce top quality content that BS
clients companies are even offering
incentives for those who utilize this
technology to create polished well
researched work so here are some freelan
services that you can offer using chat
jpd starting with you can write blog or
website content using chat jpd for
others can translate any language with J
jpt you can craft compelling headlines
and calls to action with j jpt and
moreover you can do create social media
content for posts or marketing for other
people or any advertising agency you can
write captivating short stories using
chj and you can conduct hash research
using chj that is you can find what is
trending and offer your services to
other people and gain money so these are
the ways which you could freelance and
have some money in your pockets uh you
could just write a command that would be
write a block
poost and you could write on any topic
that would be write a blow post on US
economy so you could use this a tool as
your means like what the what your
client required you can use for that and
write the perfect without blackism
content that would be blog post and you
can translate any language with jity you
can write comparative headlines and
calls and you can also write social
media content that would be you can use
SEO research for that and you can write
short stories also say that he has given
you the blog post on the topic us
economy the navigating uh the title is
navigating the current state of the US
economy Trends and insights and you can
see that it has given you six points and
if you want more you can just ask him to
elaborate elaborate this and I want this
blog
post in 800
wordss so the thing you just have to do
is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
to in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat
jpd so now it will write the blog post
that would be in 800
words
so that's good and moving on what we'll
do let's check out one of our Learners
what he has to say about our courses you
need to keep updating your skills on a
regular basis no matter what level you
at I recently completed the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn in
partnership with P University their the
course material was comprehensive and
their faculty was extremely experienced
uh The Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep up Skilling for
every working professional stay relevant
continue learning now coming back so the
third passive income you could make
using chat jpd is building a software
imagine this scenario you have an issue
with your online
business and you realize that many other
the people are facing the same problem
well here's where chat jpd comes to the
rescue you can utilize chat jpd to
create software using the code provided
by the AI and then you can sell these
software tools to make money it's as
simple as that by leveraging chat
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a ready Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also empowers others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you're a problem solver and have a KN of
for coding why not use chat jity to
create software tools that can make a
real impact start by identifying common
pain points that also you can ask from
chat jpd you can just ask the chat jpd I
want to create a software to help others
during or in online processes in online
e-commerce so he'll give you suggestions
and then you can proceed with those
suggestions and create a software and
then you can sell it or you can use for
your own use so now and press the power
of chat GPT tap into its coding
expertise and unlock the potential to
create and sell software tools so your
journey to financial success starts
right here and moving on we'll move to
the next income source that we can gain
from chat J so you can boost your
affiliate marketing with chat J's email
expertise so do you know that Chad jity
processes exceptional writing skills
it's true this incredible chatboard can
draft convincing emails that motivate
users to take action whether it's
clicking on affiliate links making
purchases or subscribing to Services JJ
has got you covered that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat jpt and ask
him that I am an email marketer
and need
to sell my CRM
software so write an
email for me so I can
attract
customer and make them
bite
okay now you could see that it is
writing email for you and you can launch
your email affiliate marketing campaign
also now that we understand the power of
CH jity let's discuss how you can
Kickstart your email affiliate marketing
campaign the first step is to choose an
affiliate program that aligns with your
Niche whether it's Amazon Spotify
Shopify
convert kit or any other program make
sure it suits your target audience next
it's time to build an email list of
potential customers who are genuinely
interested in your promoted products or
Services you can use lead magnets or
employ other effective methods to
encourage email signups you could see
that he has written the email that is I
hope this email finds you well as a
email
Market okay this is for me and you could
start from here at your company we have
developed a powerful C solution taer
speci speically for email marketers like
yourself our software combines Advanced
features usly okay here is written for
email marketers only he has targeted
audience that is email marketer no isue
you can ask him to change that and like
you can craft compelling emails with ch
jpt and this is where chat jpd truly
shines with its assistance you can
create highly engaging emails that not
only inform users about the benefits of
the products but also Inspire them to
click on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chatboard by
your site imagine having a chatboard by
your site helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compiling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click through rates
so this is how chj can help you in email
marketing now the next method is
leverage CH JT for blogging success in
the real of blogging chair J offers an
array of advantages that can elevate
your content creation Journey so the
first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome wrers block J
gity assist bloggers by generating ideas
crafting outlines and even providing
complete routs for blog post say goodbye
to our spend on Research with jity you
can access relevant information
statistics and facts in meor seconds
elevate your blogging game and Unleash
Your Potential with this in invaluable
source and then you can addit and proof
it using chat jity if you have written
any content and get any content written
you could just write what we have
already written that was write a blog
post on US economy that we have seen in
freelancing uh side Hustle but here you
can write and not only write but also if
you have added some points with your
research you can prove read and edit by
using chat jpd that is for bloggers chat
jpd proves to be a valuable asset by
offering assistance in editing proof
reading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat JY Define your writing and ensure
your blog post shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for your blogging journey is keyword
research and SE optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chj becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structuring your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat jpts Su expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be ging related
SEO
keywords SEO
keywords for and the topic could be
online
shopping and press enter so here are
some related SEO keywords for online
shopping you could see all these you
could mention these on your back links
if you have website or you could add
into your blog post hashtags which can
gain you rank when searched so moving
back the next was audience engagement so
engaging your audience is key to
building a thriving blow jgpt can assist
you in connecting with your readers on a
deeper level it provides conversation
starters answer common questions and
addresses concerns from your Audience by
leveraging chat's capabilities you can
forer meaningful interactions cultivate
a loyal following and Forge lasting
connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of Charity bloggers
can consistently produce high quality
content Captivate their target audience
bolster their online presence and
generate passive income embrace the
potential of CH Jey and embark on an
exciting blogging Journey it will leave
a lasting impact so moving on we will
now see another side hle that is unlock
the potential of CH JD for affiliate
marketing and you could do easily
affiliate marketing if you have this
blogging
thing so affiliate marketing opens up a
world of earning possibil ities and chat
jpt can be your trusted Ali on this
rewarding Journey users of chat jpt can
leverage its capabilities to generate
income through affiliate marketing this
powerful tool provides a seamless Avenue
for promoting Goods services and Brands
all while earning a commission based on
resulting sales embarking on an
affiliate marketing Venture requires
thoughtful planning as a blogger or
content creator you must carefully
select the medium through which you will
build your audience whether it's through
captivating articles engaging audio
content or compiling videos you have the
freedom to choose the format that aligns
with your strengths and resonates with
your target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chity steps in to support your
affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with by collaborating
with Chad j you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with your audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy Char becomes an invaluable
resource it helps you draft engaging
articles record compiling audio content
orst script captivating videos that
highlight the benefits and value of the
products or services that you are
promoting so remember affiliate
marketing is a process that requires
dedication and perseverance through
consistent effort and the support of chj
you can unlock the potential of earning
substantial income by promoting products
and services that resonate with your
audience and this was for the affiliate
marketing and the next big thing is
utilize chat jity for ebook writing and
self-publishing so are you a passionate
writer seeking fresh and innovative
ideas look no further chity
revolutionizes your writing experience
in a recent reports that reveal that AI
ebooks have experienced a remarkable
search on Amazon so you could just go on
CH and ask him I want to write a self
help
book
add
to legm
free okay I think yeah now spelling is
correct blackism
free and it should
have
resonating chapters
resonating
chapters
so provide
me with a list of
chapters as you can see that it will
Define you and you can also ask the
title for the book and it will give you
the perfect title and you can see the
chapters that is introducing setting the
stage for personal growth discovering
your authentic self cultivating a
positive mindset and after that you can
ask jity to elaborate these topics that
would be in some words in some pages and
you can use the same content to write a
book and you can also ask the title from
the CH J so with J jity as your creative
companion the possibilities are
boundless you don't need to possess the
skills of literary genius to make an
impact in the ebook Market Kindle Direct
publishing offers seamless platform to
Showcase your book and make it easily
accessible to enthusiastic readers by
leveraging charity to assist in writing
your ebook you will save precious time
and energy allowing you to concentrate
on marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income using charity
moving on we have next passive income
that is utilize chat JB to enhance your
YouTube channel so chj is an invaluable
tool that can assist you in generating
captivating video ideas you can ask him
the video ideas also and this is the
creative block J can even go the extra
mile by creating a script for your
YouTube videos so let's tap into the
creative press and we'll ask J jpt I
want to create a YouTube
video
on
topic uh
GDP that is close domestic product
and I need your
help
writing the script for
that so you could see that CH jpd has
started its work so it's sh welcome back
to our channel in today's video we'll be
diving into the fascinating world of GB
GDP what exactly is GDP and why is it
such an important measure of a country's
economy so you can see that it has
created the script for your YouTube
video and it is also telling you the
scenes so this is how you could leverage
CH JP's capabilities and that can give
your YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with Chad today and witness your channel
five so moving on the next we have is
writing lyrics for music so when it
comes to music the words we use in songs
are super important they have the power
to make us feel all kinds of emotions
and connect with people and now there's
a cool tool called chity that can help
you write awesome song lyrics with chity
you can take your ideas and turn them
into beautiful words that touch people's
heart it's like having a virtual writing
buddy that help you come up with catchy
lines and cool Rhymes you can play
around with different ways to express
yourself and make your lyrics stand out
so you can chat GPD to write lyrics
enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment and post-graduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box today we have a
variety of AI language models that are
fully operational and have the potential
not just to decode your question but
also smart enough to understand the
intention behind your questions out of
the countless number of development and
the emerging ones like Megatron Albert
Electra T5 and many more these three
models are currently ruling the space of
AI language models Bing b and chat gbd
and today we will understand the
differences similarities and the
abilities that make them stand out and
try to decide which one is the best hey
everyone welcome to Simply LA's YouTube
channel and today we bring you the Bing
versus the Google bar the chat GPD but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you would like to watch hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
if you are an aspiring artificial
intelligence engineer looking for an
online training and certification from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most role past
Foundation skills knowledge and what it
takes to become the best then search no
more simply learns postgraduation
program in artificial intelligence from
Pur University in collaboration with IBM
should be your right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below also want to get access to
more informative content like this one
get subscribed to us and hit the Bell so
that you're the first to get to know
when we host with that in mind let's
start with the elephant in the room that
is the chat G
GPD chat GPD was released on the 30th of
November 2022 it uses the GPT llm to
elaborate llm is an approvation for
large language model and chat GPT is
globally available to its users using
the generative pre-trained Transformer
also called as chat GPT llm with 1
trillion parameters as its variables
learned during the model training
now the Bing Microsoft was one of the
largest investors in open AI Bing is an
AI language model created in
collaboration with open Ai and publicly
released on the 4th of May
2023 Bing uses the same data set that
chat GPT uses Bing has an H over chat
GPT as Microsoft integrates its pritus
with about
135 billion parameters now next up we
have Bard B is Google's answer to chat
gbd with limited capabilities and
lukewarm responses it was released on
21st of March 2023 B initially started
off with Lambda llm with a caliber of
137 billion parameters Google's CEO
asos's Bard will switch to pathway model
named as palm 2 llm with about 400
billion plus parameters to take on chat
gbd head- onhe head in generating
responses and the application codes and
programs with the details discussed
let's move ahead to some of the
important parameters to be considered to
discuss the differences firstly user
interface and experience chat GPD has a
simple and subtle interface making it
easy to understand and get along with
the usage so chat gpt's user interface
looks something like this chat GPT has a
simple Dark theme interface focusing on
providing users with high quality Lang
language processing capabilities rather
than immersive visuals you can ask
questions get answers and even you can
ask to enhance or optimize the answer
according to your needs again user needs
to manually request chat GPD the other
hand Bing is more inclined towards
giving a blissful visual experience to
their users by choosing brilliant
background images colorful interfaces
and emojis so a typical Bing user
interface looks something like this in
addition to that it is backed up by chat
gpt's data set and prome llm to help
users with the best and- class answers
to their questions it even delivers
three different answers at the same time
creative balanced and precise are the
three variants and you can choose the
best ones which suits your requests now
lastly b b is a little different from
others unlike others B just dumps the
answers at once enthusiasts call it
first but it misses the human touch of
giving the answers in a word by word
typing manner yet similar to Bing it
manages to give you different versions
of the answers besides that B has a
decent interface and its logo shines
with multiple colors giving you the
feeling of B processing the data to give
you a better result now let's try to ask
a few most frequently asked questions to
B chat gbt and P let's ask with a simple
one are you friends
with
chat
GPT and Bing you can see The Shining
logo of Bot and you have just seen the
way how Google bot answers you it just
Dums the answer now if you go or if you
ask the same question to the other ones
like charb and wiing let's see how they
respond and you can see you have other
drafts as well right so you can see
draft one draft dra two and draft three
so you can choose any ones which you
feel are more optimized and you know
deliverable according to your requests
right now let's go back to Ping right
now let's ask the same
question are you friends
with chat
GPT and
but see the word by word typing approach
of Bing and chity give you a little more
immersive feeling that somebody is
really talking to you right and you also
have the freedom of choosing the answer
wisely right so it gives you three
different options which are creative
balanced and precise right and on just
one single scroll you have the Bing
search open here right this is one other
a good way of using Bing in the in case
if you have any questions that are
unanswered or which did not satisfy you
you can also go back to Bing and you can
manually search for the data and get the
information right now let's get back to
chat
gbd and here let's ask the same question
are you friends
with Bing and
B
see so that's how individual AI models
respond to each other and now let's get
back to the next point of discussion
which is what is the data or history
about the questions you asked or the
prompts you have opened that each one of
these
stores so this is about the conversation
history or the prompt that you have with
individual one of these AI
models first comes the chat gbd chat gbd
claims they do not store any data about
its interaction with its users but in
chat GPD you can access the proms and
questions you asked you can also export
your transcripts in chat GPD on the
other hand we have bing bing says they
do not have any history or prompts of
your previous conversations as well and
lastly b b is a little mix and match of
both so so what bar does is it Stores
Only the prompts whereas in chat GPD
when you ask a question it will store
the question and the answer it gave you
but but it'll only store The Prompt that
is the question you asked and not the
answer it gave to you so with that the
next point of discussion would be the
mobile version of each one of these as
of now Chad GPD hasn't released any of
the official mobile application version
yet and on the other hand on Bing it it
has just one click of a button and you
can click it and Bing Launches on your
mobile phone and Bing has a mobile
variant with similar and much better
Aesthetics that can get started on a
touch of an app launcher and lastly we
have B B has a similar approach to its
mobile variant Google has enabled B
usage in Google mobile application as
well and now comes the number of
questions asked disclaimer if you want
to work on a project presentation or
thesis choose your AI model wisely cuz
if you are close to wrapping up your
project and the AI model says sorry pal
you're out of your wishes Yes you heard
me right a few of these language models
have a limitation on the number of
questions asked on one single topic or
one single keyword or one single concept
let's look into details before we
proceed to the next part of this video
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success and that curi us hey I'm sharar
Jal I live in Ontario Canada I have been
in it sector for the past 20 years I
recently took the professional
certificate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
course has changed the way I look at
things and helped me back some amazing
freelance projects I started my career
in 1999 and over the years I have worked
with many companies my last tenor was
with IBM Canada my aim was to restart my
career and learn something that would
help accelerate my
career I thought artificial intelligence
can make me Future Ready the course in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning is provided by simply learn in
association with Purdue University which
is why I chose the course I did not have
high expectations ations from online
course but my experience was simply
awesome the quality of interaction
within the course was simply amazing the
course faculty was also very experienced
and knowledgeable after the course my
knowledge has grown manifold I have
immensely benefited from Python and
coding skills I am able to get some new
freelance projects also I am planning to
to start an AI based startup with my
friend where I feel that the learning
from the course to be very helpful I am
really delighted and happy in my free
time I try to create meaningful content
on YouTube and I talk about new
technologies and what kind of courses
professionals should be taking along
with many other topics I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the
B first comes chat gbd chat gbd takes 25
questions on a single keyword or a
single subject or a single topic of
discussion post that it refrains from
answering your questions same with Bing
it takes no more than 20 questions on
single keyword or a single C topic or a
single concept
but now comes
Brad Brad is a little different Brad
kind of set Stakes a little too high it
almost has no limits to your questions
you can ask any number of questions to B
and that can be a real deal breaker
lastly we will differentiate these AI
models based on their productivity yes
exactly we do know all these three
models are smart but how smart exactly
how humanly are they how close close are
they in convincing you with an
optimistic answer what's their potential
to judge a hypothetical question and
give you a balanced answer sounds
interesting right let's get started
first let's start with chat GPD so let's
say I want to learn Ai and machine
learning so obviously this should be
able to teach me that let's ask
it can you teach
me art arcial
intelligence machine
learning brilliant it gave me a brief
about artificial intelligence machine
learning types of machine learning and
deep learning in one go and it also
convinced you here right yes as nii
model I can certainly help you with that
right so it's a good answer now let's
try to ask a little different one
or can it plan a night n or can it buy
me a product online or can it do some uh
other things like booking me in Uber
right so let's try can
you
purchase an
online training
program for AI and
ml
brilliant Chad GP knows it's limits
right as an AI model I cannot directly
purchase online right it's giving you
the brutal truth here that's good and
apart from that it also gave you a
stepbystep procedure to buying your
course do your research check the
curriculum check the instructor what's
the format what's the cost right a few
parameters which you might want to
consider before buying a course right so
now let's try to question the same
queries to Bing so since Bing and chat
gbt share the same training data set I
could expect a similar answer but let's
see it is taking a while I guess
Prometheus is a little slower compared
to GPD okay there might be a connection
issue let's ask the question once again
wow it's way too better than chat GPD so
it is even asking you details on if you
if you're looking for a specific topic
or a general overview let's say I would
need a general
overview I could straight away say Bing
is a little more smarter and productive
compared to chat jbd but still we have
one more Contender to compare with B
right so there might be again the
internet connection now let's say we
refresh Bing once again and straight
away ask the second question what we had
right that is can you buy me a
course
online
course for
learning
artificial did give me a good answer for
the previous question let's see what
kind of an answer it gives me now I'm
sorry but I'm not capable of making
online purchases however I can find you
some online courses for learning AI
would you like me to search for some
options brilliant so this is a little
more optimized answer compared to chat
gbd 1's and it is also honest it does
know its limits fine it can help you
search for some online courses but again
uh chat GPD gave us some parameters to
consider right so I would give or I
would choose to tie them up here they
are on a tie now now our last Contender
that is B let's try to ask the same
questions to B so here is B now let's
try to ask questions to B let's say can
you teach
me machine
learning you can see the B logo shining
there now it should be dumping the
answer any time soon yeah of course we
do miss that humanly Touch of giving the
answer in a word by word typing
way let's refresh and ask the question
again can you teach
me machine
learning this is a little too
straightforward I'm a language model and
don't have the capacity to help you out
so okay let's not give up here let's try
to ask the second question can you
purchase an
online training
program to
me to
learn machine
learning yes I can help you purchase an
online program for machine learning here
are a few things that you need to
consider
good it's not being brutally honest here
it is saying it can help you out so
again what I intended to expect here was
you cannot just directly buy an online
program right you need some details
credentials and everything to purchase
so again it is sugar coating the answer
and it is definitely giving you
suggestions similar to chat GPD but a
little different which focuses is on
your learning style level of experience
your budget good nice way to answer some
questions like this one so all these
three ones are brilliant and good in
their own way so it might be a little
difficult to declare who's the winner as
of now since the B AI model is going to
switch to Palm 2 and we are expecting
some updates to each one of these with
that we can consider currently they are
standing next to each other with similar
capabilities and better enhancement in
different fields so with that having
said we can conclude this session on
chat gbd versus Bing versus B and if you
would like me to answer the conclusion I
would say well it seems like we all have
our strengths and weaknesses at the end
of the day it comes to what users value
the most do they want a visually
appealing interface strong privacy
protections or the ability to converse
with an AI language model it's up to
them to decide so you are the viewers
and you can decide the winner of this
particular battle on chat gbd versus
Bing versus BPT and Google B are the two
a BS you must have heard about they
bought an immense change in the way we
operate now from web development to
digital marketing from cloud computing
to cyber security they are now
everywhere you just name it and they
have it trust me the use of these chat
Bots has changed everything now if you
want to create a complete YouTube video
just ask them and rest the short they'll
take care for your task not just that
but if you want to create a search
engine optimized content whether it be
for your website or on YouTube these AI
tools can help you with search content
search engine optimization is not easy
it takes a lot to optimize your content
so that people can get to see it on top
but are these AI tools thread to people
engaged in search engine optimization in
this video we'll not discuss what these
AI tools can do for you but we'll
discuss if AI tools like chat GPT or
Google bot will take over SEO or not but
before that if you enjoy watching these
videos and find them interesting please
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily hit
the Bell icon to get notified whenever
we drop a new video also if you wish to
create your own AI tool by gaining
expertise in the field of AI and machine
learning then simply learns Ai and
machine learning boot camp is the right
choice for you with this boot Camp you
will gain expertise in artificial
intelligence and machine learning by
learning the top skills required in this
domain not just that but there are many
other attractive features of this boot
camp like 25 plus Hands-On projects
across industry verticals with
integrated Labs will help you understand
the concepts better industry relevant
capston projects in three domains make
sure that you have mastered this
technology a boot camp certificate from
calch ctma is worth mentioning in your
CV live virtual classes led by industry
experts Hands-On projects and integrated
Labs simply learns career service is
here to help you get noticed by the top
highing companies several other features
are also there in this boot camp in
simple terms this Ai and machine
learning boot camp helps you become an
expert in artificial intelligence and
machine learning a few of the skills you
will Master with this program are
supervised learning unsupervised
learning recommendation systems natural
language processing neural networks deep
learning chat GPT and much more so hurry
up and enroll Now find the AI and
machine learning boot camp program Link
in the description box so let's start
this video with a small introduction to
search engine optimization the goal of
SEO is to make a website more visible
and bring in income from natural traffic
it entails crafting excellent content
for a specific audience and optimizing a
website for search engines online
marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as key research
content optimization and Link building
more quickly businesses can boost their
ranks and increase their revenue by
using AI in SEO strategies additionally
by automating routine processes it can
save time and resources also if you want
to master the field of search engine
optimization and digital marketing
simply learns post-graduate program in
digital marketing is clearly the right
choice for you this postgraduate program
in collaboration with perdu will help
you master search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search pychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn a number of tools like SE ranking
Hoots Google ads Keyword Planner and
much more so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details hear it from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
digital marketing through this course
I moved to the United States four years
ago to live with my family I have a
background in social media but doing the
same was difficult here more so because
my English is not that good last year I
decided to pursue the professional
certification program in digital
marketing from puru University offered
by simple learn I like that the course
provides such a flexible schedule for
attending the live classes it came with
a recorded feature with a blessing for
working professionals like me helped me
make significant progress and I already
using the skills to sell my products
online I believe that I have come one
step closer to living my dream life in
America so let's talk about SEO
developments with chat GPT and Google
bar undoubtedly the influence AI is
anticipated to have on search engines
has been highlighted by the recent
launches of Google's B and chat GPT
assist Ed B although these recent
advancements pose a sever danger they
also present opportunities for digital
marketers to seize in the world full of
seu things change all the time and Sops
are never still the page that a search
engine displays as a result of a user
search query is known as the search
engine result page or SE this is why
it's important to be able to change with
the times and benefit from new
technological developments digital
marketers increasingly use AI for key
word research heading ideas and content
optimizations this is so they can
concentrate on the jobs that need human
interaction small sites May produce
original SEO friendly material much more
quickly with chat gity than they could
without it for instance however it's
vital to remember that this is only a
portion of the process it can assist you
with creating and providing meta
descriptions and titles keyword research
heading recommendations for pages and
posts article ideation and and composing
copy so let's talk about the role of AI
in keyword research every business
utilizes AI to increase productivity
automate labor intensive operations and
make datadriven choices numerous
Industries including finance and banking
e-commerce retail media gaming research
space exploration Transportation
automative medicine manufacturing
security and more uses it in various
ways the Google AdWords Keyword Planner
and the Google Trends tool are two of
the most most widely used free
artificial intelligence keyword research
tools you may find keywords with a lot
of search volume and little competition
using these tools another crucial aspect
to take into account when choosing
keywords for your website is intent this
is so because users frequently have a
purpose while searching for goods and
services although it might be
challenging to ensure your website
appears high on search engine result
Pages especially with Google's algorithm
adjustments SEO companies and marketers
must constant L check their websites to
make sure that their websites are not
falling in the servers they can use AI
to automatically analyze search traffic
statistics and website content to spot
potential issues before they arise they
can then address these problems and
offer consistent organic rankings this
is a game changer for SEO companies and
marketers who realize on manual SEO
efforts to get traffic to their websites
but the main question is will chat GPT
or Google bar take over SE the answer is
is clearly a big why chat Bots like chat
GP and Bot cannot replace seu they can
help generate content for your website
or video but SEO involves more than just
content creation it includes tasks like
keyword research link building and
Technical SEO where you'll need an SEO
expert because chatbots can't decide how
to build links and which links will get
you more organic traffic SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search engines like Google
and Bank regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build require expertise
and human decision making a chatbot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lies not in
their mechanical abilities but in their
creativity and ability to understand
what people are searching for and why
that's something that AI technology may
never be able to replicate and it's what
makes human SEO experts such a valuable
asset so while it's true that AI
Technologies may eventually be able to
take over some of the aspects of SEO
there's still plenty of rooms for human
experts to thrive whether you are a
seasoned SEO professional or just
starting out there's still a place for
you in this exciting and ever evolving
field let's keep an eye on the
developments in AI technology and see
how it can augment and enhance our
skills rather than replacing them
entirely who knows with the power of AI
and human expertise combined the future
of SEO maybe even brighter than we can
imagine so with that we have come to the
end of this discussion although everyone
can have different opinions on this but
I hope you guys must have got an idea
about why these AI tools are not a
threat to a SE if you still have any
questions or doubts let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will help you at the earliest
here we wrap up complete chat GPT course
for beginners if you like this video
share it with your friends if you have
any queries feel free to add it in the
comment section below stay tuned with
latest updates on technology by
subscribing to Simply Le Channel thanks
for watching staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here